Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim. Du, der Sommer kann kommen. Es gibt jetzt Einhornwurst, Einhorn Bier, sogar Einhornschokolade.
Fehlt eigentlich nur noch ein trojanisches Einhorn. Oh weit.
Lokbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertvierundzwanzig und wir sind gebieten worden mal das Datum zu sagen, auch wenn das ja irgendwie so eine Geheiminformation ist, ne?
Freitag der dreiundzwanzigste.
Das fiel mir vor ein paar Tagen auch auf, da hatten wir auch so Freitag, der dreiundzwanzigste, das klingt irgendwie viel besser als Freitag, der Dreizehnte.
Genau, Freitag der dreiundzwanzigste und zwar der Juni im Jahre zwanzig siebzehn. Dies ist eine Botschaft an all die Leute, die diesen Podcast in fünfhundert Jahren nochmal nachhören und äh sich vielleicht äh an dieses Datum erinnern werden als den Tag, an dem.
Johnny Kramer Star. Nein, äh ein Tag eins nach dem Staatstrojaner.
Nachdem und wie die Einhörner uns betrogen haben. Weil die einer, der jetzt wie eine sitzen bitte, CDU Schwufen gehen.
Ja, da kommen wir gleich nochmal zu. Ähm also.
Aber wir müssen vielleicht vorab nochmal äh zu entschuldigen, wir waren etwas abwesend. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lange waren wir denn jetzt weg.
Zwei, drei Wochen.
Genau, wir hatten äh Dinge zu tun und du warst wieder viel auf Reisen.
Das ist richtig.
Ja, dritter Juni, wir waren jetzt tatsächlich drei Wochen.
Ich muss sagen, ich muss die Podcasterhandtasche mal wieder äh ins Reisegepäck Standardstandard aufnehmen. Ähm unter Umständen bisschen Remote arbeiten wieder.
Das könnte im Juli äh auf jeden Fall ein Thema werden und im August werden wir uns ohnehin etwas zügeln müssen.
Ja, wir werden uns auch, also wir haben uns ja eigentlich vorgenommen, wenn jetzt der Sturm der Überwachungsgesetze vorbei ist, kommen ja nicht mehr so viele, ne? Diese Legislaturperiode, also nicht.
Fällt jetzt nichts mehr ein.
Gibt ja kaum noch was, äh dass wir dann äh uns mal äh also wir haben so einen Plan, wir müssen mal gucken, wie wir den umgesetzt kriegen.
Jetzt mit der Rakete und dem anderen Planeten.
Außerhalb der so viel Meilenzone nur noch,
Nee, äh vielleicht äh wollen wir vielleicht schaffen wir es ja ein paar Netzpolitiker äh unterschiedlicher Couleur in die Sendung zu bekommen und dass äh euch da dann mal die Wahlentscheidung ein bisschen zu erleichtern.
Das war so ein Gedanke.
War sein Gedanke. Mal gucken ähm ob wir, ob die Lust haben mit uns zu reden und wir noch Lust haben, mit denen zu reden.
Ja, das ist in der Tat eine Frage. Also da gibt's, glaube ich, solche und solche, da müssten jetzt eigentlich ausholen so ein paar professionelle Trumpsche Dinalisten am Start sein, weil anders kann man das kaum noch erklären. Und der Rest ist wahrscheinlich auch genauso frustrierend.
Ja, also vor allem ähm gut belastet, ne? Also wir ich hatte das ja in der letzten Sendung schon angesprochen, die.
Die die in der Opposition tätigen den sieht man nicht keinem persönlich zu nahe treten aber man sieht anders man sieht ihn an, dass sie gerade keine acht Stunden Tage mehr haben, ne? Die haben richtig was um die Ohren und ähm,
Werden wir mal schauen wie ob die auch Zeit haben. Muss nicht unbedingt eine Frage der Lust sein.
Genau, irgendwann brauchen die auch mal Urlaub da. Von daher müssen wir uns wahrscheinlich dann auch sputen. Gut, werden wir alles sehen. Ähm heute wird's ein bisschen tragisch. Fangen wir äh mit dem ersten Akt an im ersten Staatsakt.
Ja, Staatstroana-Gesetz wurde gestern irgendwann, ich glaube, es muss so gegen neunzehn Uhr oder so gewesen sein, entschieden, wurde beschlossen. Hm, war.
Formulierungs äh der Formulierungsvorschlag wurde eingepfleg.
Ja, der hat ja jetzt auch einen wieder einen anderen Namen, das heißt jetzt irgendwie, also es war ja auch ne, im Rahmen etwas,
größerem und zweite, dritte Lesung hat der Bundestag einfach gestern mal kurz,
durchgezogen, dann wurden da wie immer vor leerem Plenum die Reden zu Protokoll diktiert, ne, die eh schon jeder kannte. Hm, es war noch ein interessantes,
Also man kann sich die Aufzeichnung glaube ich anschauen, man kann ja sehen was Hans-Christian Ströbele war natürlich da und hat da wieder queroland und hat einige wichtige Punkte.
Angebracht. Unter anderem, dass sie auch gesagt hat, na ja, wenn wir diese Mittel jetzt zur Verfügung stellen, die Richter, die darüber entscheiden, die wissen ja gar nicht.
Was das, was die ganze Angelegenheit für einen Hintergrund hat, ne? Es wurde ja die Diskussion.
Dessen, was daran wirklich problematisch ist, äh sehr geschickt aus manövriert, ne? Wir lesen in den Medien die ganze Zeit was davon, der Staat darf jetzt WhatsApp abhören, ne, was
ja eben die technische Entsprechung oder die technische Diskussion ist ja hier tatsächlich eine eine sehr viel andere ähm,
Und ähm überhaupt war ich, wenn man sich das mal anschaut, das hat jetzt genau einen Monat und eine Woche gedauert. Denn diese Formulierungshilfe wurde herabgereicht. Ähm am fünfzehnten fünften,
Das ist das Datum, was sie trägt. Sie wurde der Öffentlichkeit zwei Tage später zugetragen durch Veröffentlichung bei Netzpolitik Org,
Zwar der siebzehnte fünfte und ähm dann, ne, war meine Anhörer oder also war die Anhörung im Rechtsausschuss, wo ich ja auch als Sachverständiger war.
Und dann äh war das Ding am einundzwanzigsten sechsten im Bundestag. Äh am zweiundzwanzigsten sechsten im Bundestag. Sagt zu, ne? Das ist exakt einen Monat und ein Tag. Bin ich gestern mit einem Freund unterhalten, der sagte,
eine derartige Dynamik ist man doch vom Gesetzgebungsprozess äh gar nicht mehr gewohnt und das wäre doch irre
wo kämen wir hin, wenn die jetzt in der Lage wären, einfach mal immer so zu agieren, ja? Da könnten wir hier richtig was erreichen in diesem Lande, aber ist natürlich ganz klar, dass dass sie das auf diesen kurzen Zeitraum gequetscht haben zu diesem Zeitpunkt, mit diesen.
Mit dieser Fülle an anderen Sachen, das war Kalkül und das ist ja auch das, was ich primär,
Anpranger. Ich will nur mal ganz kurz, weil wir in der letzten Sendung war ich ja wirklich ziemlich müde, haben wir auch erklärt wieso. Ähm weil ich da eben drei Tage Marathon mit Stellungnahme schreiben und Anhörung und so weiter hinter mir hatte.
Primärpunkt ist die Quellen TKÜ ist ja eher so ein theoretisches, juristisches Konstrukt zu sagen wir greifen an der Quelle ab und wir machen das nur dann wenn der Messenger auf ist,
wenn eine Nachricht empfangen wird oder weitergegeben wird. Das stimmt zum Beispiel in bei diesem Gesetz gar nicht, weil sie ja auch Retrograd äh eingreifen dürfen. Äh also das heißt, sie kommen nicht nur ab Zeitpunkt,
Wir dürfen jetzt abhören, sondern ab wir haben den Zugriff, dass sie dann auch in die quasi Nachrichtendatenbanken gehen und sich das.
Von der Zeit davor holen.
Also zum Beispiel auf dem Gerät, wenn man sich des Gerätes hat habhaft machen können.
Genau, Sie haben jetzt, äh, Sie haben das Gerät infiziert,
Jetzt kommt der Quellenticker Ütrojaner und das erste, was der macht ist, sich die Datenbank der gespeicherten Nachrichten nehmen und die auch nach Hause telefonieren. Also quasi ähm.
Etwas, was mir sonst aus der Vorratsseitenspeicherung kennen, ne? Ähm nämlich, dass du sagst, okay, wir haben so und so viel Zeit, zeitlichen Rücklauf und holen uns die Daten nach Richterbeschluss. Das haben wir jetzt auch in dem Abhören dieser Nachrichten.
Wanze und Tonband.
Ja, aber du, also niemals hattest du die Möglichkeit, etwa, dass du sagst, wir bringen die die Maßnahme an und haben dann aber noch in der Zugriff auf die Vergangenheit,
Das gibt's ja nicht. Das gibt's erst seit der seit.
Weil das Tonband ja schon drin ist im Gerät so.
Das hättest du ja einbauen müssen und dafür hättest du, dann hättest du den Richtervorbehalt schon, ne? Also Retro gerade, Retrograder Zugriff gibt es nicht,
außer in der Vorratsdatenspeicherung und dann nur auf Meterdaten. Das war der Begründung, warum äh Saskia Esken dagegen gestimmt hat, kommen wir gleich nochmal zu. So
Ich will nochmal ganz kurz erklären, warum es QuellentKÜ ein theoretisches Konstrukt. Ähm abgegrenzt wird die Quellen TKÜ von der Online Online-Durchsuchung, Online-Durchsuchung ist,
Du hast Vollzug auf alles, äh, ne, darfst auch alles, ne? Kannst irgendwie akustische Wohnraumüberwachung machen, wenn du das jetzt für für notwendig hältst, du darfst ähm,
alle Dateien auf dem Computer durchsuchen und so weiter.
Wer in TKÖ heißt, du darfst nur Kommunikationsvorgänge nehmen. Herausforderungen bei der Quellen-TKÜ ist, es gibt ja,
quasi unendlich viele Möglichkeiten wie Leute kommunizieren können.
Auf verschiedenen E-Mail-Anbietern, E-Mails schreiben, es gibt eine Fülle an Apps, äh die da vorhanden sind. Und um dem juristischen Ziel der Quellen TKÜ.
Zu entsprechen musst du ja für alle diese einzelnen Möglichkeiten einen in Anführungszeichen minimalinvasiven, genau gezielten Zugangssektor haben und sagen wir haben eine Möglichkeit ähm.
Für Signal. Wir haben eine Möglichkeit für WhatsApp. Wir haben eine Möglichkeit für Freemer. Wir haben eine Möglichkeit für Telegramm. Wir haben eine Möglichkeit für Wee-Chat. Was auch immer die Leute nutzen wollen.
Und das Entscheidende ist in der Architektur von so einem Smartphone sind die Applikationen, die da drauf sind, voneinander separiert, also die Applikation A,
kommt nicht in den Bereich von Applikation B, sie kann noch nicht, sie weiß noch nicht einmal, dass sie da ist. Und äh das ist ein sehr schönes Sicherheitsfeature, ne? Nen.
Genau. Dieses der Sandkasten.
Hinzu, also du, du, das Ziel dieser Smartphones ist, dass die Applikation selber so wenig wie möglich
überhaupt ihre Umgebung und das Betriebssystem weiß. Wir hatten ja sogar vor einigen Sendungen auch mal wieder über diese Judy ID gesprochen, dass die Applikation noch nicht einmal mehr herausfinden können sollen,
was der Unique Identifier des Telefones, auf dem sie sind. Sie sind bei, also bei Apple insbesondere,
Vollständig eingeschlossen in einem Bereich, wo für sie jedes Telefon so gleich wie möglich aussehen soll. Dem anderen.
Das ist der eine Punkt. Ähm der zweite betrifft die Codesining-Mechanismen, die verhindern sollen, ähm dass du überhaupt,
Ein nicht autorisierter Applikation ausführst. Diese beiden Sicherheitsmechanismen musst du umgehen, um um überhaupt Quellen TKÜ zu machen. Muss also.
Irgendwie das Betriebssystem dazu bringen, dir Rutrechte zu geben und das Code Sining außer Kraft zu setzen und dann kannst du natürlich auch als Rout äh in die anderen Container der Applikationen reingehen und dann kannst du dort spezifisch nach Dateien suchen oder äh die Applikation verändern. Die,
Eingriffstiefe ist dabei aber bereits schon die einer Online-Durchsuchung,
Technisch gesehen. Das heißt, du kannst gar nicht mehr spezifisch eine Quellen-TKÜ machen, sondern du hast technisch auf jeden Fall eine Online-Durchsuchung,
von der ich nenne das immer Penetrationstiefe des Zielsystemes.
Und ähm dann kannst du dich nur noch juristisch ähm vielleicht zügeln.
Eine auf die auf die Extraktion von Quellen-TKÜ-Daten. Aber du musst das.
Zu beschränken auf bestimmte Kommunikationen und nicht einfach den Vollzug zu machen auf alles.
Den du aber technisch auf jeden Fall hast. Na ja, sonst kannst du keine Qualität machen
jetzt kommt nicht der Punkt. Wenn du das nämlich nicht hast, dann hast du nämlich genau das, was wir früher gesehen haben
zweitausendelf beim Staatstrainer liegt das CC, dass sie nämlich genau schon damals gesagt haben, wer gibt Outlook, gibt Sander Bird, gibt Pegasus Mail, gibt Hasse alles nicht gesehen.
Also ist viel zu kompliziert für jedes einzelne Anpassung zu machen. Wir fotografieren einfach den Bildschir.
Wir fotografieren einfach alle zehn Sekunden den Bildschirm und da wo keine E-Mail im Bild ist, da löschen wir wieder.
Genau, das können wir dann, das können wir dann mit unseren eigenen Selektoren dann wieder heraus äh filtern und wir haben da kompetentes Personal und die wissen ja auch, das ist ja alles rechtsstaatlich und überhaupt
So läuft's nämlich, weil das ist nämlich einfacher ist
einfach mal ein Fulltake zu machen und dann rüber zu bürsten, was man da vielleicht von gebrauchen kann. Aber das ist halt einfach eine volle Überwachung und keine gezielte Maßnahme.
Also Punkt eins, Quellen-TKI ist ein theoretisches, juristisches Konstrukt, für das es keine technische Entsprechung gibt. Und das Entscheidende dabei ist, dieses Auslösende Moment, dass eine Nachricht angekommen ist oder dass eine Nachricht geschrieben wird, dass
Um das überhaupt zu erkennen, musst du schon vollständig rot sein und was mehrere Sicherheitsmechanismen des Zieltelefons ähm übergangen haben.
Genau, wir beruht sein, nicht versteht, gemeint ist der Vollzug ohne Einschränkung durch das Betriebssystem Chef sozusagen.
Ohne Einschränkung alles auf dem Gerät dürfen. Zweitens, das habe ich aber glaube ich das letzte Mal schon ausreichend ausgeführt. Ich will's nur nochmal wiederholen.
Schwachstellen sind das Problem, um diese Dinge anzubringen, brauchst du mehrere Schwachstellen und diese brauchst du auf allen Systemen und das ist das Kernproblem für uns als Gesellschaft, wenn nämlich der Staat diese
Das Wissen über dieses Schwachstellen geheim halten muss, um sie zur Anwendung bringen zu können und das ist das Problem, warum auch unbescholtene Bürger
hier.
Gegen sein müssen und damit und das Risiko haben unter die Räder zu kommen. Das also äh Schwachstellen, diese Sicherheitsevolution vom Staat gezielt gebremst wird, viel Geld dafür ausgegeben wird, dass Geräte und zwar alle
unsicher gehalten werden und diese Unsicherheiten können andere ausnutzen.
Die Gefälle der inneren Sicherheit.
Genau. Jetzt äh wo das Kind im Brunnen ist pur in Fontim habe ich mir gestern von Google erklären lassen, heißt, das Kind ist im Brunnen. Ich kann euch jetzt auch Latein. Ich möchte ja auch.
Heißt Kind. Oh ja. Pur. Was heißt das denn sonst? Keine Ahnung, ich kann kein Latein, aber.
Was heißt das denn sonst? Also keine Ahnung, vielleicht vielleicht haben wir intellektuelle und Hörer.
Wie mehr können als Google Trumps Laser bedienen.
Deswegen habe ich's auch nicht getwittert, weil ich ja wusste, dass ich dann eben äh Puer in von dem äh Kin.
Jetzt hast du es aber gesagt, ne?
Kind ist im Brunnen. Ähm und was passiert? Jetzt kommen die ganzen, jetzt kommen die ganzen ähm Journalisten.
Und sagen, also wirklich mehrere,
in den letzten Tagen, die mich angeschrieben haben oder angerufen haben und sagen, sagen sie mal, Herr Neumann, ähm ich ich habe mir das hier gerade mal angeschaut mit diesem mit diesem Staatstrojaner. Das ist doch eigentlich eine große Nummer, oder?
Sage ich, ja, ist eine große Nummer, eine ziemlich schlimme Sache, weil ähm ich habe das irgendwie nicht ganz auf dem Radar gehabt.
Gesagt, da machen sich keine, also das ist natürlich schlecht, aber das äh machen sie sich bitte keine nicht nur persönliche Vorwürfe, weil das ist der Strategie, der schon der,
Parlamentarier oder der Regierung hier ähm,
entsprechend und genau darauf haben die ja auch abgezielt. Ja und dann schaut man sich diese Zeitleiste an, dann schaut man sich an, wie sie das unten reingefegt haben mit in welcher Masse gerade Überwachungsgesetze kommen und da ist die Strategie der Regierung aufgegangen. Das war genau das Ziel.
Ähm.
Finde ich aber natürlich trotzdem wirklich erschreckend. Das sind eben auch Situationen, in denen es mir, wenn ich da mal ruhige Minute habe, was in letzter Zeit selten ist, aber da läuft natürlich auch kalt den Rücken runter,
wie da die Journalisten hinters Licht geführt werden und wirklich unsicher sind
ne, dann merkst du, diese Strategie, dieses Gesetz so zu vergraben, hat so gut funktioniert, dass die Journalisten da sitzen und ihrem ihrem eigenen Urteil.
Quasi nicht mehr trauen, dass sie sagen, oh, das ist eine krasse Nummer. Da hat aber niemand anderes so richtig drüber berichtet, ähm dann ist das wahrscheinlich nicht so krass und dann merken sie, oh, der CCC hat doch was dazu gemacht. Daher gab's eine Anhörung,
letzte Woche so mehr oder weniger vor zwei, drei Wochen und.
Da muss ich doch jetzt mal fragen, was da los ist. Keine kaum eine Debatte in der Öffentlichkeit, das haben sie wirklich. Und das war eben Absicht des Aufgegangen. Na ja, es gibt eine schöne,
Ein schöner Artikel von Markus Reuter auf Netzpolitik Org.
Der das Ganze auch mal ins Größere, ins größere Gefüge einordnet, einsortiert wird und das erklärt vielleicht auch so ein bisschen, warum Leute wie ich, die sich damit irgendwie nicht hauptberuflich, aber inzwischen,
Hopp, zeitlich oder wie nennt man das? Primär mit sowas,
Auseinandersetzen, eben auch einfach mal durch sind. Die Liste der grundrechtsfeindlichen Gesetz der großen Koalition ist lang.
Von der Wiedereinführung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung über die Erweiterung der Befugnisse des Bundesnachrichtendienstes bis zur Ausweitung der Videoüberwachung hat diese Regierung wenig ausgelassen was dieses Land weiter in den Überwachungsstaat treibt. Die Budgets der Geheimdienste erhöht und ihre Unkontrollierbarkeit versteckt
ausgebaut. Den Diensten nebenbei vollautomatischen Zugriff auf die Passbilder aller Bürger gewährt und die massenhafte Handydurchsuchung für Flüchtlinge eingeführt,
Mal von der Speicherung der Fluggastdaten aller Bürger ganz zu schweigen. Und ich habe mich gestern, bevor ich diesen, bevor dieser Artikel erschien oder ich ihn gesehen habe, echt gefragt.
Was geht denn eigentlich noch? Meine These ist, es gibt eigentlich ähm wenig,
was sie noch machen können, weil sie haben mit der mit der Vorratsseitenspeicherung den Zugriff auf alle Meterdaten. Äh sie können ähm mit der
Telekommunikationsüberwachung ohnehin auf alles, was nicht verschlüsselt ist, zugreifen und jetzt können sie mit dem Staatstrainer auch auf das verschlüsselte zugreifen. Da muss jetzt echt schon kreativ werden, um dir noch was einfallen zu lassen. Es gibt noch etwas. Markus schreibt, der Hunger ist damit nicht gestillt. Die düsteren Träume der Hardliner gehen immer weiter. Fort, Datenspeicherung für.
Neun Stoff. Du weißt, dass wenn wir uns die jetzt äh ausdenken.
Haben die schon, ist schon alles, ist schon alles, das ist äh er berichtet nur über die Pipeline. Er berichtet nur über das, was sie schon da liegen haben. Vorratssentenspeicherung für Postsendungen.
Wir denken uns jetzt nicht gleich noch was Neues aus.
Nein, gibt's schon, gibt's schon, ich passe auf, dass äh Erfassung aller Reisebewegungen, Gesichtserkennung im öffentlichen Raum, Fußfesseln für alle möglichen Täter, Verknüpfung,
Von Geheimdiensten, Polizei und Daten töpfen alles alles schon da, ja,
Garniert mit dem gerade eingeübten Einsatz der Bundeswehr im Inneren und Gesetzen die Ordnungshütern.
Noch nach oberigkeitsstaatlichem Vorbild eine Sonderrolle zuweisen, wird,
Unter dem Deckmantel der Terrorismusbekämpfung mit Verweis auf ein subjektives Unsicherheitsgefühl. Mittlerweile alles gerechtfertigt. Ohne Augenmaß, ohne jeglichem Beweis von Effizienz.
Wirksamkeit. Ähm, wobei ich hier glaube ich effizient nochmal das falsche Wort wäre, Effektivität, noch nicht mal die Effektivität.
Nur dass es nicht einen Beweis gibt, sondern es gibt auch da hatten ja auch schon mehrfach gerade bei Vorratsdatenspeicherung sehr wohl Beweise dafür gefunden, Studien. Das ist eben genau das nicht hat.
Ähm eben auch der Punkt, den wir immer wieder fordern, dass solche Gesetze wenigstens mal unter dem Druck stehen,
ihren Erfolg an irgendeiner Stelle mal innerhalb, was weiß ich von Jahren unter Beweis zu stellen und dass sie sonst eben ungültig wieder werden, ne? Wäre doch nicht zu viel verlangt. Ja, nein, nein, nein, sowas können wir hier nicht machen.
Wüsste man ja direkt, was dabei rauskommt, dass dann nämlich am Ende nehmen die uns die Befugnisse wieder weg, ja.
Ja und am Ende kriegt man schon das Gefühl, dass diese Gesetze auch nicht unbedingt erlassen werden, um äh effizient zu sein, sondern anderen Aktivitäten Vorschub zu leisten.
Ich habe, weil ich ja, weil wir ja so als Kritiker und Gegner dieser Angelegenheit ähm bisschen allein auf weiter Flur standen, ein bisschen auch den Drang mal renommierte,
Personen hier zum Wort kommen zu lassen, um ein bisschen zu zeigen, dass das eben nicht nur wir sind, die dagegen sind. Auch so ein bisschen um diesen ähm
dieser von Maßen vorangetrieben oder die, ich weiß nicht, ob es von Maßen vorangetrieben ist, bei Maßen habe ich das zum ersten Mal gesehen, also im Verfassungsschutz,
Chef, dass er sagt, äh sagte inzwischen auf jedem Podium. Es gibt in Deutschland eine sehr starke Datenschutzlobby,
die mental in den siebziger Jahren zurückgeblieben ist, als es noch keine Digitalisierung gab. Das ist immer so sein Satz, den er jedes Mal,
Ne, wir sind wir sind die ewig gestrige Lobby im Prinzip, ne? Heribert Brante schreibt in der Süddeutschen Zeitung,
Man soll nicht bei jeder Gelegenheit von einem Skandal reden. Aber das, was heute am späten Nachmittag im Bundestag geschehen soll, ist eine derartige Dreistigkeit, dass einem die Spucke wegbleibt,
ein Gesetz mit gewaltigen Konsequenzen, ein Gesetz, das den umfassenden staatlichen Zugriff auf private Computer und Handys erlaubt, wird auf fast betrügerischer Weise an der öffentlich ver
Öffentlichkeit vorbeigeschleust und abgestimmt. Es ist kein Eingriff in die Privatsphäre, der hier stattfindet, sondern ein Einbruch.
Heribert brannte Süddeutsche Zeitung.
Peter Schar, der ehemalige Bundesdatenschutzantrag. Angesichts dieser sehr schwerwiegenden Auswirkung halte ich es für für unverantwortlich, die entsprechenden Überwachungsbefug, wo Nisse in einem parlamentarischen Schnelldurchgang ohne
Möglichkeit zur gründlichen Prüfung und Debatte zu beschließen,
Andrea Vosshof dazu geschrieben hat, habe ich äh in der letzten Sendung schon ausführlich zitiert, dass sie nämlich aus den Medien darüber erfahren hat, dass es überhaupt diese Pläne gab und niemand,
Tick Ork, weil da der, weil da das Ding geliegt ist, ja? Geliegt, das kommt ja noch dazu, dass er geliegt.
So, dann gibt es ähm die CDU.
Die eine Pressemitteilung oder eine Blogpost oder was auch immer das dann ist, dazu formuliert.
Und da kippst du wirklich hinten über. Ne, die also das ist einfach nur noch.
Unverschämt, das ist bös, böswillig, ja? Sie schreiben.
Die Innenminister, die Innenminister von Bund und Ländern hatten sich auf der letzten Innenministerkonferenz auf eine Überwachung von Messengerdiensten,
verständigt. Man war sich einig, dass Sicherheitsbehörden rechtlich und technisch in die Lage versetzt werden müssen, etwa zur Terrorabwehr, auch auf Nachrichten von Messengerdiensten,
zugreifen zu können. Zu Terrorabwehr wurde hier nicht mehr diskutiert. Wir reden hier von.
Der alltäglichen Strafverfolgung. Für Terror hat das BKA diese Befugnisse seit zweitausendacht. Das ist Teil meiner,
Sachverständigenauskunft, einen Rechtsausschuss des Deutschen Bundestages und man hätte ja erwarten können, dass selbst die CDU, die vielleicht liest. Aber nein, aber nein, weit gefehlt. Denn hier wird zitiert,
Winkelmeier, Bäcker, wahrscheinlich Herr Winkelmeyer-Bäcker. Wir halten die vorgesehene Regelung für erforderlich und auch für Verfassungskonform. Dies hätten auch die Experten der Sachverständigenanhörung bestätigt.
Die die Anbieter von Telekommunikationsdiensten dürfen sich nicht gegen eine angeordnete Überwachung sperren, den Sicherheitsbehörden müssten die Maßnahmen ermöglicht werden, heißt es im Gesetz.
Also, ich erinnere mich an ähm einen Herrn äh Ulf Burmeier,
und einen einen Herrn Linus Neumann, die äh Experten bei der Sachverständigen an,
Hörungen waren und sicherlich nicht gesagt haben, dass das erforderlich ist und erfassungskonform ist. Und ich,
Würde er sogar gelten lassen, wenn der jetzt geschrieben worden wäre, die Mehrzahl oder sowas, ja. Was auch unzulässig ist, weil ich erinnere mich äh, dass wir letzte Woche noch die,
Unklarheit hatten, ob denn auch die Anzahl der,
Sachverständigen, die man laden kann, tatsächlich sich nach dem Proports richtet und ob das gesetzlich so vorgeschrieben ist oder nicht. Andre hatte uns dann sehr schnell in den Kommentaren, also Andre Meister von Netzwerk Dick Oc hatte uns schnell gesagt, ja ist so, richtet sich nach dem Propost. Ähm,
Und ist wohl auch so geriegelt. Der entscheidende Punkt, weil dass sich das, dass das immer so ist, dass die, dass du mehr Sachverständiger hast, das habe ich halt auch beobachten können in, aber es ist eben auch so, dass es quasi so geschrieben steht.
Die korrekte Formulierung äh hätte heißen müssen, die von uns.
Bestellten.
Lacköre, äh waren äh bereit zu klatschen.
Die von uns aus, die von uns, genau, die von uns ausgewählten Sachverständigen haben gesagt, was wir wollten.
Ne? Gut, umgekehrt ist natürlich auch ne deswegen bin ich ja immer von der Opposition da, ja? Was meinst du, wie schnell die SPD mich bestellt, wenn die auf einmal nicht mehr in der großen Koalition sind, ne? Also das äh.
Mhm. Also das äh.
Muss man dann auch noch dazu sagen. Trotzdem verbiete ich mir eine derartige,
Derartige Berichterstattung ähm zumal auch hier natürlich und das ist ja die bösartige Täuschung.
Der Öffentlichkeit. Der Titel ist Zugriff auf Messengerdienste wie bei SMS,
Es ist eben nicht wie bei SMS, bei SMS hängen sie zentral an der äh an dem SMSC oder im SS sieben drin und schreiben den Mist mit und ähm,
bei Messengern geht es eben nicht, ne? Und dann Tim, was hauen sie uns? Sie haben,
Inzwischen so viel Oberwasser für ihren für ihre äh für ihre tiefgreifenden Angriffe auf die Grundrechte und auf die Sicherheit der Bürger, dass sie uns auch noch ins Gesicht lachen und uns verarschen mit einem schönen Einhorn.
Das ist wirklich, das ist also ich meine, da ist wirklich echt Schluss. Ich meine, was ein Einhorn,
Jetzt mit einem Trojaner zu tun hat. Das wissen wahrscheinlich auch nur die Webmaster von CDU, keine Ahnung, aber das ist dann schon, wenn uns die auch noch wegnehmen wollt, dann heißt es Krieg.
Also was man da sieht, ist ein großes Banner, über sogar noch über dem Artikel äh irgendwie schwarz-rot-goldene Farben, weil äh das jetzt Teil ihrer neuen wie nennen sie das jetzt? Oder wie heißt der Slogan der CDU jetzt.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Für ein Deutschland, in dem wir gut und gerne leben wollen oder sowas. Raute für dieses Koffefe,
ist jetzt ja, so wollen die jetzt hier, das ist ihre Kampagne.
Von der CDU oder von der FDP. Ernsthaf.
Ja ja und in diesem Design ist das auch äh also äh sorry kommen wir gleich nochmal zu, also Grafik,
Ne, schwarz, rot, gold irgendwas, ne, so ähm und dann ein Einhorn, ein verpixeltes Einhorn, was gerade hier Männchen macht oder wie das bei Pferden heißt das anders, ne? Meine.
Sich aufbäumt.
Okay. Und daneben steht bei uns zum Download der Staatstrojaner.
Was erlaube.
Steht da nicht noch irgendwie nicht dahinter.
Nein, bei uns zum Download-Doppelpunkt der Staatstrainer. Einfach nur so so hier. Fickt euch! Das ist doch das, was sie eigentlich sagen wollten, oder?
Genau und wir wir machen euch vor, das ist ein schönes Einhorn ist, was euch Glück und Frieden bringt, aber stattdessen ist es einfach ein mit Waffen geladenes, dickes Pferd.
Ich bin wirklich schockiert. Und ich habe lange überlegt, ähm.
Es gibt schlechtes Karma, Leute. Also der damit landet man irgendwie schnell bei den Darwin Awards.
Das sind einfach, also genau, das, ich habe das mal gescreenshottet, also wenn uns das dann irgendwann Gott bewahre, doch um die Ohren fliegt, dann hole ich das wieder raus. Weil das ist einfach nur ein, also weißt du.
Diese CDU, ne? Die haben zwar andere, die haben andere Positionen, so ne und ich habe eigentlich immer,
Zumindest den Eindruck gehabt, ja, dass man da bis auf wenige Außen ach nee eigentlich.
Ich man kann ab und zu den Eindruck gewinnen, dass man es bei der CDU immerhin mit seriösen Personal zu tun hat. Ja, wenn man jetzt mal so sagt, okay, wenn man so eine Steinbach oder sowas, ne, okay, die.
Nicht mehr dabei.
Den muss man da mal außen vor lassen, ne? Und dann hat man irgendwie solche Personen wie äh wie äh Hans-Peter Uhl, die auch einfach äh wirklich,
einfach nur noch gemein gefährlich äh agieren und argumentieren und sich und die auch nicht seriös sind, ne? Aber jemand wie Wolfgang Bosbach, ja, mit dem,
An dem wir uns ja, weil ich mich ja jahrelang gerieben habe, über den kannst du viel sagen und was der macht, ist auch ist auch was, halte ich ja für falsch.
Aber der Mann ist.
Irgendwie im Vollbesitz seiner geistigen Kräfte, der hat halt andere Überzeugungen, der macht die Abwägungen, die wir machen auch.
Macht sie nur anders, ja? Aber der ist dem Argument zugänglich.
Aber mit dem, was hier passiert, wie das durchgezogen wurde, wie hier die Bevölkerung getäuscht wurde.
So kannst du nicht regieren. So verlierst du das Vertrauen der Bürger sehr schnell. Nicht so schnell wie die SPD, weil von denen hat man wenigstens noch was anderes erwartet, als solche Hütchen-Spielertricks, ja. Ähm.
Ich habe das gestern äh festgestellt, also,
In dieser, in dieser, bei dieser Entscheidung, da standen dann bei, wer ist dagegen? Immerhin zwei Personen von der Koalition auf, Lars Klingball, netzpolitischer Sprecher der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion, wenn ich mich nicht täusche und ähm.
Saskia Esken, die ähm in dem Verbraucherschutzbereich da irgendwie aktiv ist, aber die auch in dem Ausschuss saß übrigens, als ich da meinen äh Kram zu äh,
zu Protokoll gegeben habe. Die waren dagegen. Und da ist mir eingefallen, weißt du, was die da gemacht haben, Tim?
Die haben die Verräterpartei verraten.
Wenn das die.
Denn dass die, dass die SPD uns am Ende immer nochmal ein Deutsch in Rücken rammt, das wissen wir äh schon lange, ja? Und.
Ich hätte jetzt fast gesagt, da da finde ich die CD CDU aufrechter in dem, was sie da getan hat, weil es bei denen wenigstens klar war, dass sie das wollen.
Aber man kann sich dann ja mal anschauen, wie äh Patrick Sensburg gestern im Bundestag argumentiert hat. Man kann sich anschauen, äh wie Christian Ströbele äh argumentiert hat und dann kann man sich da eben seine Meinung bilden.
Aber,
Es wird wirklich schwierig. Und das ist das, was ich eben viel weiter, was der Schaden an dem Vertrauen in unsere Demokratie ist wahrscheinlich noch viel, viel größer, als der Schaden, den die überhaupt mit diesem Gesetz,
angerichtet haben. Und der ist schon ziemlich groß. Aber wenn, wenn, wenn du dir anschaust, wer so etwas
sich anschaut, wer soll denn da noch Vertrauen in diese Parteien haben? Wer soll denn da noch am Ende sagen, ja, nee, klar, die wähle ich jetzt eigentlich, wir haben ein super System in Deutschland und die Politiker, äh denen es da äh denen ist da zu vertrauen. Ich fühle mich bei denen in guten Händen,
wenn die so argumentieren, wenn die so die Öffentlichkeit sind, das hinters Licht führen, wenn die strategisch,
die Öffentlichkeit täuschen und die Journalisten im Dunkeln halten, ja? Ähm.
Vor allem etwas, was uns was gerade äh so in den USA so in Reinkultur zelebriert wird und von hier aus dann immer äh ne groß kritisiert wird und dann bringt man einfach nochmal genauso ein Ding.
Was wird gerade in den USA debattiert mit dem ähm hier Health Cable, das ist der größere Teil äh des des Sennet und der des nicht.
Keine Lesung, keine Vorlage, es wird einfach irgendwann abgestimmt, fertig aus.
Noch nicht, noch nicht mal eine eine Wissenschaft, eine noch nicht mal die äh.
Bewertung dieses äh Gesetzes durch die.
Behörde zur äh zuständig ist, dass alles nachzurechnen, was gerade nicht genau wie die heißt. Äh sogar das äh ja, wollen sie nicht abwarten, beziehungsweise nicht veröffentlichen.
Das ist wirklich übel.
Aber es geht noch weiter wie äh wie die Öffentlichkeit hinters Licht geführt werden soll. Hennes Auer, der NS-Auer Abschlussbericht. Tim guck mal.
Ja, ich wollte nur kurz darauf hinweisen, dass wir noch viele, viele, viele Links haben, die ihr euch vielleicht mal durchlesen sollte
diesmal, da ist äh eine Menge äh zu holen. Wer das sozusagen das,
Wem das Geschehen so ein bisschen nicht nur am Arsch, sondern auch am Hirn vorbeigegangen ist, äh kann da nochmal eintauchen, einiges hast du ja hier schon äh zitiert.
Gut, dass du das sagst, aber ja, nochmal auf Kai Biermann und Patrick Beuth auf Zeit online verweisen, die haben das Gesetz, seit ein Wort für Wort sitziert, mal so richtig auseinandergenommen
tolle Arbeit, schade halt, dass es Erscheinungsdatum glaube ich der einundzwanzigste oder zweiundzwanzigste war, da wo es eben dann leider zu spät war. Ähm,
Dann natürlich hier Heribert Brante mal zu lesen und ich mein bei der CDU mal nachzufragen, wo man den Scheiß Trojaner denn runterladen kann. Ähm.
Ja
Na gut, kommen wir weiter äh zum nächsten Thema. Wir hatten ja da so einen Untersuchungsausschuss, den wir hier nun hier wirklich in Ipscher-Breite
begleitet haben, teilweise wurde an anderen Stellen noch in noch epischerer Breite begleitet. Podcast technische Aufklärung und natürlich die ganzen Liveberichterstattungen und Nachuntersuchungen und Diskussionen auf Netzpolitik Punkt org
Jetzt ist das Ganze ja zum Ende gekommen und es gi
gibt dann den Abschlussbericht, wo dann drin steht, was man alles gelernt hat daraus, ja äh dass das soll sozusagen gleich mit solchen
Maßnahmen und und neuen Gesetz,
Initiativen begleitet wird's natürlich nochmal extra lächerlich, mal ganz abgesehen davon von dem, was vorher alles schon gelaufen ist. Aber man lässt halt kein äh Fettnäpfchen aus,
und äh.
Mal kurz.
Erlaubte sich auch noch an Iklat zum Schluss.
Genau, da haben sie sich da kurz zu erklären, was da jetzt äh was dahinter den Kulissen jetzt in den letzten Wochen passiert ist. Du hast die Mitarbeiter, der,
der Fraktion, weil die die für diesen Untersuchungsausschuss Ausschuss abgestellten Mitarbeiter und die sitzen dann da zusammen und sagen, was haben wir denn jetzt hier gelernt in diesem Ausschuss, da muss ja dann der Bericht,
geschrieben werden und dann sagen, dann sagt eben zum Beispiel jetzt jemand von den von den Grünen, sagt dann hier, wir haben ja zum Beispiel gelernt, dass äh Telefonnummern sich eignen für,
Drohnentötungen und dann sagen die äh da sagen die Mitarbeiter von SPD und CDU,
Wo haben wir denn das gelernt? Und dann sagen die, ja hier steht doch da, ne? Ja, nee, aber das äh haben wir an, das haben wir anders gelernt,
Und so hangeln die sich eben diese gesamten Bericht entlang und zanken da äh jeweils über die Inhalte. Und jedes Mal, wenn.
Ähm jetzt die Koalitionsleute sagen, nee, das lehnen wir nicht rein, das wirft ja ein schlechtes Licht auf uns,
Dann geht das in das sogenannte Minderheitenvotum. Das heißt, dann schreiben jene.
Die eben, also ne, die Opposition, die es eben aufgrund der zahlenmäßigen Kraftverhältnisse nicht geschafft haben, das da reinzuschreiben, ähm sagen dann, okay, dann schreiben wir das eben in dem getrennten Minderheitenvotum, wo wir sagen, das, das ist unsere Ansicht,
über die wir als Minderheit auch nochmal darüber abstimmen und die dann eben dem Bericht angefügt wird. Anders kann sich die Opposition da kein Gehör verschaffen. Das ist das, was da jetzt gerade stattgefunden hat.
Und dieser Abschlussbericht soll am Mittwoch äh an den Bundestagspräsidenten Norbert Lammert übergeben werden. Dann wird er am Donnerstag,
im Plenum des Parlaments besprochen. Und jetzt sagt die Große Koalition, ja,
Das ist super, also ich frage mich eh wie die, wie die am Mittwoch dieses Ding, ne? Also der, der, der, dieser Bericht
der besteht aus drei Teilen. Verfahrens zahlt zweihundert Seiten Feststellungsteil zweitausend Seiten und dann eine Bewertung. Dieser letzte Teil dieser Bewertung sind einhundertsechzig Seiten Bewertung der aus von den Regierungsparteien und vierhundertsiebenundfünfzig Seiten der Opposition
sowas wird am Mittwoch dem Lammert gegeben und am Donnerstag diskutiert. Ja.
Lesen sie mal.
Hier reden wir morgen eine Stunde drüber. Machen wir für achtzehn dreißig, da guckt gerade keiner Phönix. So, ne? Ähm.
Ähm.
So und jetzt dieser Teil der Opposition, diese vierhundertsiebenundfünfzig Seiten.
Ähm also sowieso inhaltlich kannst du dir natürlich jetzt schon sagen, die große Koalition sagt natürlich mehr oder weniger auf ihren ähm einhundertsechzig Seiten ähm,
Gehen sie weiter, hier gibt es nichts zu sehen. Es findet weder eine anlasslose noch eine flache, flächendeckende Massenüberwachung statt und äh eine,
Alles super, ne? Wer die Opposition natürlich sagt, die Massenüberwachung war,
unzulässig und für Massen und so weiter. So, jetzt sagt die,
Jetzt sagt die Opposition, eure vierhundertsiebenundfünfzig Seiten, wo wir immer schon gesagt haben, das wollen wir eh nicht haben. Da sagen wir jetzt,
Das soll ähm da am besten mal erstmal nicht mit veröffentlicht werden,
Denn der Ausschussvorsitzende Patrick Sensburg, wir wissen, ne, der, der sein Buch über diesen Ausschuss schon längst veröffentlicht hat, ja, der Mann.
Hat jetzt vorgeschlagen den Bericht der Opposition zunächst als geheim einzustufen denn es könnten ja geheime Dinge wie die Worte Glutaik oder Monkey Schulder oder Zitate
Aus dem von uns veröffentlichten Bericht der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten darin sein
Wir erinnern uns, der von, also von Network Tick Ork, veröffentlichte Bericht der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte, ist nach wie vor geheim
Kann jeder lesen, mein Netz für Tick Org darf aber nicht Bestandteil des NSA Untersuchungsausschussberichtes sein, weil Chile drei geheim,
ja? Und äh der ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie viele ähm wie viele Rechtsverstöße äh die das der die Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte da ähm,
dokumentiert hat. Die sind aber alle geheim. Deswegen dürfen die nicht im Abschlussprojekt stehen und damit die auch nicht im Sondervotum der äh der der Opposition.
Ist es auch geheim.
Ist das auch geheim? Und diese vierhundertsiebenundfünfzig Seiten, die die Opposition da in ordentlicher Manier zusammengeschrieben hat, äh die sollen deswegen jetzt erstmal geheim eingestuft werden
und damit nicht an das Licht der Öffentlichkeit kommen, weshalb sie jetzt ähm bei Netzpolitik Hork schon mal veröffentlicht wurden.
Papa. Super Aktion.
Was erlaube Sensburg.
Seiner war das dann eine alleinige Entscheidung oder.
Das sieht denn vielleicht auch jemand anders noch vorgeschlagen haben, aber der der Vorschlag selber kommt jetzt an die.
Ich meine, ist das eine Abstimmung oder ist das sozusagen ein Beschluss des Vorsitzenden.
Na ja, das ist äh das spielt ja wahrscheinlich, steht ja bei den Messen Mengenverhältnissen selten noch eine Rolle.
Tja. Na ja.
Ja so und das äh letztendlich, ne, vom Statement, äh die jetzt zitiert werden, ne? Also es im Prinzip will man das in der Geheimschutzstelle versenken. Ich meine, schreib mal vierhundertsiebenundfünfzig Seiten, ja? Und die.
Wird's noch nicht mal veröffentlicht.
Konstantin von Lotz. Ohne inhaltliche Begründung und Beleg,
Beschließt die GroKo unser Sondervotum zum NS-Auer geheim einzustufen. Ähm Martina Renner, Sondervotum der Linksfraktion und Grüne zum NSA durch GroKo in Geheimschutzstelle ohne Begründung versenkt. Arroganz der Macht.
Äh Martina Renner hat dann gegenüber Netzwerk Ork kommentiert. Das gab es noch nie. Der Fortsitzende zitiert in seinem Buch, aus eingestuften Akten
und hatte offensichtlich seinen Ghostwriter dafür auch,
gegeben und gleichzeitig lässt er das Sondervotum der Opposition geheim einstufen, obwohl in unserem Votum keine Geheiminhalte stehen. Mit der letzten Sitzung des Ausschusses setzt er damit der Bigotterie der Koalition die Krone auf.
Ähm.
Das ist wirklich unfassbar.
Es ist unfassbar und weißt du was? Ich meine, ganz ehrlich. Da draußen sind eine Menge Lohne Ticks unterwegs.
Und die gehen auf sowas natürlich echt stahl.
Info war äh Style.
Na ja.
Theoretiker.
Theoretiker, irgendwelche
die dann da neben was weiß ich so komische Vokabeln in den Mund nehmen, ne? Also auf der linken und auf der rechten Seite. So und wenn du wenn du die so fütterst, meine Fresse weißt du nicht, was du da sähst
Wissen, die nicht in, also gucken, die sich nicht an, wer in den USA wohl den Trump gewählt hat und woran das liegt,
Und warum so eine Hillary Clinton da ähm als als korrupte Person gilt. Dieses Verhalten ist anders auch nicht mehr zu beschreiben. Das ist einfach unnötige
Hütchenspielertricks und der blicken natürlich einige drauf, ja? Und offenbar offenbar wiegt sich so wiegt sich so ein Patrick Sensburg in der
in der Sicherheit, dass seine Wähler ein solches Verhalten nicht mitbekommen.
Weil Gutheißen kann das selbst CDU-Wähler nicht. Ja? Und da frage ich mich auch, was was,
was daraus klingt, was das für eine Perspektive auch auf die eigenen Wähler ist. Das finde ich immer am krassesten.
Na ja, ich meine, wir wissen ja, dass das hier alles eine sehr äh komplexe Thematik ist, der zufolge nun wirklich äh äh nicht einfach ist und machen wir uns nichts vor.
Das erreicht halt auch den CDU-Wählern nicht. Nicht nur die CDU-Wähler, sondern auch eigentlich alle anderen Wähler.
Also liebe.
Darauf wird halt gesetzt, es ist halt Sommerpause, dann kommt Wahlkampf, dann zählen ganz andere Parolen, da redet keiner über Abschlussberichte von irgendwelchen komplizierten Spitze verschiedenen
und mit äh vielseits schießet äh Material durchsetzten, diskussionsstrengen. Ist so, ja.
Ich mach das ja eigentlich nicht, aber wir könnten ja an dieser Stelle mal äh die unsere Hörerschaft äh
unser Hörerschaft naheliegen, doch vielleicht diese eine Episode dieses Podcasts ungefähr die erste dreiviertel Stunde vielleicht mal der ein oder anderen Person aus unserer nicht klassischen Zielgruppe zu empfehlen. Da haben wir doch mal ein paar Sachen im
ein paar Sachen hier in Ruhe durchdiskutiert. Ähm wir beliegen normalerweise nicht um Empfehlungen und so, aber das wäre doch mal vielleicht,
strategisch angebracht im Hinblick auf die Wahl.
Oh, hoffe ich mal, dass wir da schon äh nicht zu viel vorwissen äh vorausgesetzt haben.
Vielleicht vielleicht äh schaffen wir da dann vielleicht auch einen Wissensdurst. Aber um mal wieder zum Inhaltlichen zu kommen. Ähm.
Vierzehn Punkte werden in diesem Sondervotum der Fraktion die Linke und Bündnis neunzig die Grüne Kritier angebracht kritiert. Ähm.
Erstens, sagen sie, dass es also eine Blockadehaltung der Bundesregierung gibt und die von dieser Mehrheit in diesen ähm,
NSA Untersuchungsausschuss ähm aufrechterhalten wurde. Also,
dass quasi ähm der Ausschuss selber stark,
blockiert und begrenzt wurde in dem, was er anschauen konnte, ne? Wir erinnern uns an die vielen ähm,
Wege der Einsichtnahme, die dem Ausschuss verwehrt wurden und zwar mit der Ausschussmehrheit, wo quasi die
Koalition selber den Ausschuss ausbremst, weil er ja gegen sich selber gegen sich selber ist. Das heißt da eine ganz klare,
Eigeninteressen, Konflikte.
Zweitens kritisieren sie, dass äh Edwards Norden nicht gehört wurde, der nun meinte, der Einzige und der Kronzeuge dieser gesamten Angelegenheit ist.
Drittens, sagen sie, dass es eine Massenüberwachung in Deutschland und auch international gab und dass die auch durch deutsche Dienste zu verantworten ist,
anlasslose und unzulässige Massenüberwachung hat die Beweisaufnahme nicht nur im Rahmen der Operation Eikonal festgestellt, sondern,
Darüber hinaus wird es NSA und BND Selektoren, auch deutsche Staatsbürgerinnen und Unternehmen waren davon über Jahre betroffen.
Viertens, die Kooperation des BND mit der NSA in Bad Aibling. Das Memorandom of agreement, eine Vereinbarung von zweitausendzwei zwischen BND
und NSA über gemeinsame Telekommunikationsüberwachung in Deutschland sollte der NSA auch Zugriff,
ähm auf Daten am Frankfurter Netzknoten verschaffen, war jedoch mangels nötiger Zustimmung des Bundestags formell unwirksam. Da fragst du dich am Ende, welches Ergebnis überhaupt noch in dem Votum stehen soll.
Fünftens der Datenangriff in Frankfurt ähm hat ohne G zehn Anordnung stattgefunden. Zwischen zwei der Abgriff der Angriff auf Frankfurt.
Abgriff. Der Abgriff.
Ja, also da geht's darum, zwischen zweitausendfünf und zweitausendacht fanden in Frankfurt am Main im Rahmen der gemeinsamen Operation Eikonal,
mit der NSA Datenabgriffe durch den BND ohne Rechtsgrundlage statt. Entgegen massiver Gedenken
Bedenken der eigenen Mitarbeiterin wurde die Operation namegeschwärzt, ohne dass es dafür G zehn Anordnungen gab.
Dass es eben, ne, das heißt mit anderen Worten illegal, wenn du keine GC-Anordnung hast und einen Eingriff in dieses Fernmeldegeheimnis vornimmst, dann ist das illegal.
Mit dem Abgriff in Frankfurt wird das alles wieder in Ordnung.
Willst du den den Mythos der funktionierenden Filter.
Uns näher bringen.
Sechs Jahr.
Genau, über Filter ist ja viel äh gesprochen worden. Ja, es ist die praktische Umsetzung der Operation Eikonal steht beispielhaft für den Ansatz der NSE,
Überwachungsmaßnahmen gemeinsam mit den jeweiligen Geheimdiensten vor Ort durchzuführen. Dabei war das Ziel, durch das Tauschgeschäft,
Daten gegen Technik, die Überwachungsmaßnahmen technisch entscheidend mitzugestalten, die NSA liefert Hard und Software, BND und BFV, Daten und Informationen, ja? Also.
Haben wir ja auch viel drüber gesprochen über den Einsatz, der äh Überwachungs äh Netzwerk Infrastruktur der NSA, äh Terminalzugänge et cetera, um eben diese ganzen Filter zu machen,
BND war hier äh Handlanger und,
Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz natürlich auch und hat einfach die Daten geliefert, also man war da wirklich Hand in Hand unterwegs.
Dann diese Lektoren selber.
Natürlich problematisch eines der großen Themen, Teil der Kooperation zwischen BND und NSA war und ist, dass der BND die von ihm erfassten Daten mit Hilfe von Suchbegriffen der NSA filtert, die Ergebnisse werden dann
an die NSA weitergeleitet. Punkt. Vielmehr muss man da gar nicht zu sagen. Das ist nicht gut
Und da haben wir diese gesamten Selektorenskandale, das ist nämlich der BND. Äh diese Sektoren einfach übernommen hat äh und die Daten
ohne sich anzuschauen, wonach die NSA sucht und wer da ähm äh untersucht wird äh zurückzuliefern, ne.
Ich fand was, was auch in dieser ganzen Weiterleitungs und Filter äh Kooperation,
stark rüber kam und in gewisser Hinsicht glaube ich auch für viele mich eingeschlossen so eine neue Erkenntnis war, ist einfach wie,
klar und einfach diese internationale Kooperation der Geheimdienste läuft.
Vollkommen unabhängig davon, was da gerade so für politische Spiele laufen,
in verschiedenen Vertrauensebenen läuft das so einfach bei Deford, ne? Die extremste Fall sind natürlich diese Five Eis, also die englischsprachigen Linder, Kanada,
USA, Britannien, Neuseeland,
und Australien, ja, die sich nochmal so auf einen ganz anderen Level äh vertrauen und irgendwie mehr oder weniger alles miteinander teilen
und dann halt die näheren Verbündeten zu denen dann eben Deutschland auch gehört in eingeschränkten Maße, aber trotz alledem auch einfach so mal bei. So, das heißt dieser ganze Geheimdienst,
Block, den sehe ich heute sehr viel mehr äh einheitlich, ja.
Was ein bisschen absurd ist, ne? Weil das natürlich auch schnell äh immer wieder bei dem, was du vorhin gesagt hast, ne, so schnell diese ganze,
Schwörungstheorie, das Weltumspannen,
Gesamtverschwörungsblocks ähm.
Beschwört im wahrsten Sinne. Äh herausstellt und dann ist halt irgendwie enttäuschend zu sehen, dass es dann halt an der auf der Ebene auch genauso läuft.
Ja und der entscheidende Satz ja noch über das frei erfundene Konstrukt der Vertrauensperson der Bundesregierung, die gemeinsam mit dem BND die NSA Selektoren untersuchte
wurde eine Aufklärung vorgegaukelt, die Realnie stattfand. Das war ja also echt geil, ne? Die mit diesen Selektoren können wir die mal einsinden, ne ja nee,
Also wir können, wir können jemanden entscheiden, der also eine Vertrauensperson. Das wäre immer geil, wenn du stehst als beschuldigter vor Gericht, ne? Und dann sagen die ja, hier äh können wir mal eine Hausdurchsuchung machen,
Und dann sagst du, nee, nee, nee. Also wenn äh ich, also was wir machen können, ist, ich kann eine Vertrauensperson bestellen,
Äh die mich besucht und euch nachher sagt, dass alles in Ordnung ist. Das können wir machen. So, aber sonst, ey. Also hör mal. Nachher,
Ich weiß also das wäre ja ein Skandal, wenn könntet ihr auf einmal gegen mich verwenden, das ist aber geheim. Das sind meine Geheimnisse,
Die unterliegen beim Geheimschutz. Tja, tut mir leid. Unglaublich.
Datenübermittlung des BND an die NSA aus Bad Aibling. Im Rahmen der Kooperation in Bad Aibling übermittelte der BND monatlich rund eins Komma drei Milliarden Daten an die NSA.
Der der BND-Unterschied dabei unzulässig zwischen Inhalts und Meterdaten, obwohl auch Meterdaten geeignet sind, intimstes Wissen über betroffene preiszugeben,
Meterdaten wurden massenhaft erfasst und verarbeitet. Die Rohdatenströme ganzer Kommunikationsstrecken automatisiert an die NSA weitergeleitet. Wenn du dir das mal anschaust, denn wenn das alles abweichende Meinungen sind, dann fragst du dich ernsthaft.
Welchen Ausschuss haben die eigentlich besucht?
Welchen Ausschuss haben die anderen besucht, ja. Und wie schaffen die es, hundertzwanzig Seiten zu schreiben, wenn alles, was da drin steht, ist alles ist super, hier gibt's nix zu sehen.
Neuntens, die Operation Glutaik und Monkey Shoulder, Obstattas waren die, die man nicht erwähnen durfte, ne? Neben der Operation Eikonal hat sich der Untersuchungsausschuss mit Glutaik, einer weiteren Operation des BND gemeinsam mit einem,
US-amerikanischen Geheimdienste wie der Operation Monkey Scholder, einem Projekt zur Kabelüberwachung mit einem britischen Geheimdienst befasst.
Die Untersuchung bei der Operation war nur sehr eingeschränkt möglich. Die Ergebnisse zeigen aber, dass der BND auch hier vorsätzlich an den Kontrollgremium Gremium, Gremien meine Kütte vorbeigearbeitet hat.
Zehntens.
Diese Lektoren des BND. Nicht nur die NSA sucht nach Informationen in den erfassten Daten der BND setzt auch
eigene Selektoren ein. Durch die Erweiterung des Untersuchungsauftrags wurde deutlich, dass auch diese Selektoren nicht nur die Bereiche des Auftragsprofils des BND betrafen, sondern etwa befreundete Regierung, europäische Institutionen,
internationale Organisationen, Journalisten und die Zivilgesellschaft
nicht von wegen abhören unter Freunden, das geht nicht. Also es wurde fleißig herumgegrast im Datenmaterial und dabei eben halt auch Politiker aus der EU äh abgehört, Journalisten,
viele äh weitere Personen mehr. Ja, also hat man halt einfach mal gemacht, weil geht.
Dann noch das Beste überhaupt.
Das ist auch wieder so clever ne? Eigentlich eigentlich eine schöne, muss man wirklich mal sagen, so eine schöne, man kann so richtig nostalgisch in alten Folgen schwelgen. Das No-Spy-Abkommen kennst du noch.
Flüge des Herrn Puffaler mit der Behauptung die US-Seite habe angeboten uns nicht auszuspionieren zog die damalige Bundesregierung fünf Wochen vor der Bundestagswahl zweitausenddreizehn die Notbremse um das äußerst ärgerliche und lästige Thema des Sommers einer unzulässigen und rechtswidrigen,
anlasslosen und massenhaften Aussperrungen von Millionen durch die NSA und BND zu beendigen. Diese Erklärung war falsch.
Stimmt. Stimmt, ist auch alles klar, da gibt's gar nichts zu diskutieren, dass das falsch ist. Und der wusste das ja auch. Der weiß doch glaube ich selber noch im Ausschuss, als der Pupphaller da saß.
Das wird er auf jeden Fall nie wieder los.
Konnte sich nicht mehr dran erinnern, genau.
Das wird ja trotzdem nie wieder los, das Ding mit dem Skandal wählen.
Das ist dem auch scheißegal, wo ist der gerade untergekommen.
Deutsche Bahn, aber durfte jetzt nicht Chef werden. Haben sie es dann doch den Natur aufm.
Was.
Osten gesetzt.
Ich gebe mir so Mühe, dieses politische System zu verteidigen, dann hast du solche solche Figuren.
Der blinde Fleck der Wirtschaftsspionage zwölfter Kritikpunkt, die Spionage auf die Spionageabwehr
ist Aufgabe des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz. Trotz zahlreicher Hinweise auf Wirtschaftsspynase durch
Geheimdienste sogenannter befreundeter Staaten, verharr,
BFV in den Denkmustern des kalten Krieges. Gezielte Spionageabwehr findet, wenn überhaupt im digitalen Gegenüber Staaten wie Russland und China statt bei befreundeten Staaten, wie denen der Five Eyes wird offenkundig weggesehen.
Das stimmt auch. Ich erinnere mich da, das war sogar glaube ich zwanzig dreizehn.
Da war ich auf so einer Diskussionsveranstaltung, da war das zwanzig dreizehn oder zwanzig vierzehn. Da war ich auf einer Diskussionsveranstaltung mit dem äh Chef für Spionageabwehr des Bundesamtes für Verfassungsschutz.
Und der war da auch wieder so, ja also was soll die USA denn bei uns äh Wirtschaftsspionage betreiben, der Vater habe ich damals zu ihm gesagt, waren sie denn schon mal in Detroit.
Wieso? Nee, war noch nicht, ne? Haben sie da mal die leere, haben sie mal die leere Stadt gesehen? Wissen sie, woran das liegt? Ne.
Ja, ich sage mal, die Amerikaner nicht in der Lage sind, Autos mit einem einheitlichen Spaltmaß zu bauen.
Meinen sie ernsthaft nicht, dass sie einen Grund hätten ihrer,
ihre Automobilwirtschaft mal auf die auf die Sprünge zu helfen,
Ja, aber das sind doch unsere Freunde. Er konnte selbst der der Leiter der Spionageabwehr, also der selbst dem die glauben das, ja, insofern diese Diagnose hier, dass sie in alten,
Muss dann verhaftet sind, finde ich sehr,
sehr treffen und das kann man auch einfach mal, da muss man dann vielleicht auch mal tatsächlich als Kritikpunkt anbringen. Natürlich möchte ich, dass wir eine Spionageabwehr in Deutschland haben, die ähm die deutsche Wirtschaft vor Wirtschaftsspionage.
Ja, zumal auch die NSE schon selber vor Jahren schon gesagt hat, dass gerade dieser Wirtschafts äh.
Aufklärungsteil für sie ja auch sehr wichtig ist, ja. Also es ist hier gar nicht unbedingt immer nur um die Abwährung von irgendwelchen Bedrohungen geht, sondern dass es eigentlich auch äh ein aktiver Beitrag ist, die
wirtschaftliche Vormarkstellung sicherzustellen. Natürlich gehört da das Ausspielen ja von Konzernen dazu. Zumal das eben auch,
ziemlich einfach ist, wenn man sich das Sicherheitsbewusstsein insbesondere deutscher Unternehmen anschaut
Das haben wir ja nun auch gesehen in den letzten Jahren, diese Naivität, mit der da vorangegangen wird, äh die Politiker aufgrund der Eingriffe in Wahlkämpfen scheinen ja zumindest teilweise schon etwas gelernt zu haben
Die äh Macron, aber.
Es ist halt immer noch ein totales Drama und äh ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob sich das wie jemals nochmal nennenswert ändern wird hier.
Dreizehnter Punkt.
Die Hauptstelle für Befragungswesen. Ja, wir erinnern uns, das war so eine Tarnorganisation, die vom BND äh betrieben wurde, wo ähm ja Asylbewerberinnen äh ausgefragt wurden,
In Kooperation mit US-amerikanischen und britischen Nachrichtendiensten.
Ähm aber das äh diese Befragung teilweise nur von den US,
Heimdienstmitarbeitern äh
durchgeführt wurden, das war irgendwie nicht so richtig klar, es gab da keine Rechtsgrundlage für die Befragung äh geschweige denn für die Übermittlung der Daten an die USA.
Ähm dieses dieses dieser Hauptstelle, die sogenannte für Befragungswesen äh hat halt auch da eng mit dem Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge zusammengearbeitet.
Was irgendwie auch nicht.
Ja klar war, dass so etwas so stattfinden äh stattfand und äh stattfinden dürfen,
Sabi, wurde dann zwanzig vierzehn dann aufgelöst, weil das war dann doch ein bisschen zu peinlich. Hätte aber wahrscheinlich einfach so weiter funktioniert, wenn das nicht im Rahmen des Untersuchungsausschusses auch thematisiert worden wäre.
Ja und dann letzter Punkt, ne.
Der geheime Krieg und die Rolle der US-Basis in Ramstein. Die Bundesregierung trägt Verantwortung für die Drohnentoten,
die Rolle Deutschlands im US-Drohnenkrieg ist klar, die US-Luftwaffenbasis Ramstein ist der zentrale Drehpunkt des Drohnenprogrammes in Europa. Hier laufen
nicht nur die Daten zwingen zusammen, die notwendig sind, damit die Drohnen fliegen können. Das hat die Beweisaufnahme und insbesondere die Aussage des Zeugen Brandon Briant,
ehemaligen US-Drohnenpiloten deutlich gemacht. Ebenfalls steht fest, dass die Bundesregierung seit vielen Jahren.
Die Augen vor der Bedeutung Ramsteins für das US-Drohnenprogramm verschließt. Schon zweitausendelf hatte sie Kenntnis davon, dass Entscheidungen für gezielte Tötungen in Ländern wie dem Jemen, Somalia oder Pakistan und damit der Tod
hunderter ziviler Opfer auch auf deutschem Boden mitverantwortet werden. Relevantes
dagegen getan hat sie nicht. Die Bundesregierung steht rechtlich in der Verantwortung und hat ihre Pflichten zur Herstellung von Grund und völkerrechtsmäßigen Verhaltens der US-Streitkräfte auf deutschem Boden bislang nur
unzulänglich wahrgenommen. Stattdessen hat sie jahrelang den deutschen Bundestag bei der Beantwortung direkter parlamentarischer Fragen zu dem Thema über die Sach,
eigene Kenntnislage
getäuscht.
Tja, also das ist so in etwa die Ausbeute äh dieses Untersuchungsausschusses aus Sicht der Opposition, aber das habt ihr natürlich alles nicht gehört, weil ist geheim.
Ja
Das dürft ihr nicht wissen. Ich meine, das ist ehrlich gesagt gut, da werde ich jetzt wieder korrigiert werden im Detail, ne? Aber das ist alles, was dieser Ausschuss herausgefunden hat. Ich muss jetzt echt nachdenken, wo was es noch gibt.
Was er noch heraushält, herausfinden können oder.
Irgendwas, wo die einer Meinung sind.
Ach so. Was soll man äh ob sie überhaupt irgendwo einer Meinung sind.
Na, aber gibt's irgendwo, also ich meine, klar, die also viel mehr hat dieser, das ist eine Zusammenfassung der Erkenntnisse des.
Aber was was meinen denn die, was meint denn die Koalition, was sie herausgefunden haben.
Gab keine massenhafte Überwachung, so alte Spitze. Ja, ja.
Alles super. Ah, na dann ist auch gut. Urlaub buchen und dann wieder CDU wählen.
Ich hatte, glaube ich, ja in der einen Sendung mal äh so ein paar Zitate aus Sensburgs Buch davor gelesen, ne? Also es ist machen wir weiter.
Surprise, Surprise. Die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist europarechtswidrig.
Nein. Ach.
Hat gesagt ein ähm ein Gericht, nämlich das Oberverwaltungsgericht in Nordrhein,
Westfalen ist zu dem Schluss gekommen
dass äh die Speicherpflicht ähm sich halt mit den Urteilen der Europäischen Union so irgendwie nicht vereinbaren lässt
So, also die pauschale Erfassung von Verkehrs- und Standortdaten nahezu aller Nutzer, von Telefon und Internetdiensten. Äh das würde halt einfach mal
nicht passen zu den Aussagen, die das
Der Europäische Gerichtshof hierzu getroffen hat, das hatten wir ja hier auch schon mehrfach äh erwähnt, dass diese äh Entscheidung vom EuGH mittelfristig hier ähm auch Ergebnisse in Deutschland erzielen kann. Jetzt ist es soweit. Mir ist nicht so ganz klar, wie viel Durchschlagskraft
dieses Urteil des Oberverwaltungsgerichts hat. Was meinst du.
Na ja ähm also wenn du dir die die äh die Begründung anschaust, sagen sie,
Der Beschluss ist unanfechtbar und sie begründen das, die Speicherpflicht sei eine ähm,
die die Speicherpflicht sei in der Folge eines Urteils des Gerichtshofs der Europäischen Union vom einundzwanzigsten Dezember zweitausendsechs jedenfalls in ihrer gegenwärtigen Ausgestaltung
nicht mit der Artikel fünfzehn, Absatz eins der Datenschutzrichtlinie für elektronische Kommunikation,
vom zwölften Juli zweitausendzwei vereinbar. Die Speicherpflicht erfasse pauschal, die Verkehrs- und Standortdaten nahezu aller Nutzer von Telefon und Internetdiensten erforderlich seien aber nach Maßgabe des Gerichtshofs jedenfalls Regelungen
die den von der Speicherung betroffenen Personenkreis von vorne rein auf Fälle beschränkten
bei denen ein zumindest nachvollziehbar Zusammenhang mit der durch das Gesetz bezweckten Verfolgung schwerer Straftaten beziehungsweise der Abwehr schwerwiegender Gefahren für die öffentliche Sicherheit bestehe. Also sie sagen es ist es gibt hier fertige,
Urteile des EuGH.
Kurze Anmerkung dazu, du hast zweitausendsechs gesagt, das ist natürlich jetzt von zwanzig sechzehn, also jetzt von dem was wir ja hier auch schon besprochen hatten letzten Dezember, also jetzt nicht zehn Jahre her, sondern frisch.
Also man bräuchte
personelle, zeitliche oder geographische Kriterien, mit denen man irgendwie die Vorortsseitensprechung einschränkt. Nach dem Urteil des Gerichtshofs könne die Anlasslose Speicherung von Daten insbesondere nicht dadurch kompensiert werden, dass die Behörden nur zum Zweck der Verfolgung schwerer Straftaten,
beziehungsweise der Abwehr schwerwiegender Gefahrenzugang zu den gespeicherten Daten erhielten. Ja? Also es gibt quasi äh.
Explizit wird gesagt nee nee nicht speichern, nicht nur nicht zugreifen,
Und genau das war ja auch immer der der Kernkritikpunkt an der äh Vorratsdatenspeicherung und der gilt natürlich weiterhin. Jetzt wird hier gesagt, dieser äh Verstoß ist unanfechtbar und,
diejenigen Juristen, die das irgendwie erst beurteilt haben und deren Urteil ich mir angeschaut habe, sagen na ja, das gilt jetzt heute. Das Fertig ist eine Ober äh Verwaltungsgerichtsurteil oder was auch immer das hier ist, ne.
Oberverwaltungsgericht und da wird darauf wird,
Gesagt, das muss müsste müssen jetzt eigentlich alle umsetzen. Oder da kann man sich jetzt drauf berufen.
Und entsprechend ist ja auch der der Aufruf sich jetzt an die äh an die Provider zu wenden.
Und quasi die äh Provider anzuschreiben, gibt's einen sehr schönen äh Text von Jens Kubizil, der ja sicherlich vielen bekannt ist auch als äh langjähriger Aktivist in diesem Bereich. Ähm.
In unserem Bereich, also sage ich mal, ähm ja, also sagt, schreibt eure Provider wegen der Vorratsdatenspeicherung an und dann fertigen Text auch hier, wo er äh quasi dazu aufruft, die Provider auf dieses Urteil aufmerksam zu machen.
Dass dieses Gesetz ähm,
so nicht in Ordnung ist und äh dass die Klage des Providers Space Net äh vor dem Oberverwaltungsgericht Münster erfolgreich war und,
In seiner jetzigen Ausformulierung betrifft dieses Urteil nur einen Provider, aber dieses Urteil kann, darauf kann sich jetzt jeder ähm,
beziehen. Und wenn man ähm man kann aber gleichzeitig ein ein quasi das gleiche Urteil,
wirken, indem man jetzt als Provider dagegen klagt und,
quasi jetzt die Argumentation ist da und dann würdest du als Provider einfach nur sagen, hier wie Oberverwaltungsgericht Münster äh schon dargestellt hat und die Urteile des EuGH, auf die sich das äh Oberverwaltungsgericht Münster äh beruft.
Könnte man sich drauf beziehen und.
Weil ist ja nicht anfechtbar,
Ja, interessant, ne? Also ich meine, damit war ja schon äh irgendwie zu rechnen, dass es hier nochmal einen juristischen Backtash gibt, ob das jetzt schon derjenige ist, der die Nummer zum Einstürzen bringt, weiß ich nicht, aber sieht auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz gut aus.
Meine werden wir wahrscheinlich auch beim Staatstriana ja auch bekommen, ne. Egal. Haben wir lange genug drüber geredet.
Schön, schön wäre natürlich jetzt also wenn die BN jetzt A einfach die VDS für alle pro Weide aussetzen würde, dann müsste man jetzt keine Eilanträge stellen. Ähm gibt viele Möglichkeiten, ne, aber na ja.
Ja, das beschäftigt, ich muss hin, muss noch über Stream on nachdenken.
Da könnten wir mal ganz kurz das Thema einschieben, das macht die Bundesnetzagentur nämlich gerade. Ähm,
Und da haben wir auch gestern Nacht noch ähm eine kleine äh Pressemitteilung veröffentlicht, denn natürlich ist klar, dass dieses Stream-On ein Verstoß,
gegen die Netzneutralität ist,
Und ähm wir haben wir beobachten halt gerade, dass die Bundesnetzagentur sich da sehr ähm,
Vorsichtig und man würde fast sagen, verdächtig, vorsichtig verhält, denn
Als das Netzneutralitäts äh Regul, als die Netzneutralitätsregulation ähm in Europa zweitausendsechzehn entschieden wurde. Da hatte die B Netz A sogar den Vorsitz des des Bärik
dieses Regulierungsgremiums auf Europaebene, wo die ganzen Regulierer gemeinsam drin sitzen. Und es hätte natürlich eine wirklich,
Ihre Signalwirkung, wenn selbst die Benetz A,
den Vorsitz des Bereck hatte, als das beschlossen wurde, sich jetzt hier so einen Streamern auf die Nase binden lässt und da überhaupt nichts gegen unternimmt.
Und ähm sie haben wohl, was man so hört. Sie haben jetzt einige,
Teilnehmer daran angeschrieben und haben da sich aber eben sehr, sagen wir mal nicht besonders elegant angestellt und ähm,
was man so man hat so den Eindruck, dass das quasi von der dass die von oben in Anführungszeichen politisch äh gebremst werden.
Das ist so der der Eindruck, den man da hat. Insofern haben wir uns da nochmal auch an die Bundesnetzagentur gewendet
mit einem Statement auf CCD und haben gesagt Freunde, ne, hier gibt's geltendes Recht, das ist auch relativ klar, klarer Fall alles. Jetzt äh verhelft doch bitte mal diesem Recht,
zu seiner Geltung. Problem bei diesem Stream,
wir haben da mehrmals drüber gesprochen, auch in der letzten Sendung schon, das Üble daran ist.
Dass du wenn du daran teilnehmen möchtest. Also selbst wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, möchte, ich möchte dieses haben,
für mein Dienstangebot. Dann sagt die Deutsche Telekom ja eher kommst du zu uns, ist alles klar, wir wir machen das mit allem, bei uns wird keiner diskriminiert, alle für alle gleich, ne?
Da musst du eben relativ definierte technische Anforderungen erfüllen, also was die Beschreibung deines Dienstes angeht und wenn du daran irgendetwas änderst, musst du es denen mitteilen, damit die ist ihr,
Zero Rating aufrechterhalten können, ne? Die möchten ja für die ist das ja.
Wochen im Voraus.
Für die ist das ja gefährlich, ja? Dass sie, dass du ihnen quasi einen Dienst unterschiebst.
Der nicht der für sie nicht vollständig spezifiziert ist und du es dann irgendwie ermöglichst, dass Leute quasi über dich tunneln, ne? Also,
gratis surfen wir Media CCC DE zum Beispiel, ne? Also wir haben,
Wir haben alles über HTPS und äh keine Ahnung, wupp, die du stellst sich raus.
Stellt sich raus, wir haben einen Tunneling-Mechanismus gebaut, der genauso aussieht, als würdet ihr Stream Streaming-Videos von MTC DE schauen. Tja, ähm wenn wir das machen würden, können wir machen.
Teil des Vertrages mit der deutschen Telekom wäre, aber dass wir für bis zu fünfzigtausend Euro haften. Für den Fall, dass das passiert.
Da kannst du natürlich nicht mehr von einer niedrigen Eintrittshürde sprechen, wenn äh wenn Menschen quasi, wenn wenn Dienstanbieter, die daran teilnehmen möchten, unterschreiben,
dass sie im Zweifelsfall mit fünfzig K,
fünfzigtausend Euro Haftung übernehmen. Das ist natürlich für so jemand wie die Telekom irgendwie ein Kleckerchen,
Aber das da kann man nicht von einem äh von einer neutralen Eintritts.
Wobei man jetzt noch dazu sagen sollte,
Das war jetzt so ein Szenario mit, wir tun jetzt was sozusagen was anderes, als wir gesagt haben, selbst wenn man das tut, was man sagt, aber.
Kriegt halt ihr technisches System nicht auf die Reihe, fängt an den Leuten dann trotzdem äh Gebühren zu berechnen, obwohl die darauf setzen, dass es bei deinem Dienst nicht der Fall ist, obwohl du es vielleicht richtig dokumentiert hast
ja?
Äh oder weil sich der Dienst auch in dem Maße so nicht greifen lässt, wie die technische Spezifikation das vorsieht mit hier, wenn mal deine IP-Adressen et cetera, weil das einfach alles viel dynamischer
ist und sein muss als als die Telekom sich das vielleicht gedacht hat bis zu in der selben Problematik,
Aber ganz unabhängig davon, dass man da eben auch noch potenziell drunter leiden kann und dass auch diese
Vorwarnzeit von ein paar Wochen äh teilweise halt äh
Eigentlich viel zu viel zu viel Zeit ist, um äh schnell auf den Markt noch auf irgendwas reagieren zu können
dann ähm stellt sich halt einfach generell die Frage,
wenn so ein Dienst halt da ist, äh äh wie willst du mit jedem Provider auf diesem Planeten da äh entsprechende Deals machen? Das geht einfach alles gar nicht, ja? Wie ist die Zugänglichkeit für Anbieter aus anderen Ländern,
Das ist einfach eine Marktverzerrung.
Dann kommt es eine marktverzehrende Stelle mal vor, ne? Das macht jetzt das macht jetzt irgendwie äh wenn er mal das macht jetzt Schule,
Und jetzt fangen die anderen auch noch an.
Dann bist du nämlich als Anbieter nicht mehr nur in der Position, dass du einen Vertrag mit der deutschen Telekom hast, wo du mit fünfzigtausend Euro in der Haftung stehst. So, da musst du mit den anderen Anbietern auch noch einen machen und am Ende mit jedem und dann wahrscheinlich sogar noch welchweit.
Alles doppelt und dreifach.
Und das das wäre eben, das ist dann leider, ne? Für kleinere Anbieter eben nicht mehr zu schaffen.
Es ist auch, glaube ich, irgendwann für, ist auch für
größere nicht mehr zu schaffen, weil wo ist denn bitte die Liste aller Provider? Also ich meine, das Internet basiert ja nun nicht unbedingt auf einer geschlossenen Liste, sondern äh hinter Providern können Provider hängen
et cetera äh das ändert sich auch am laufenden Meter, es ist unmöglich so einen Dienst zu machen, irgendwann bist du nur noch damit äh,
beschäftigt äh sozusagen die Infrastruktur bei dir rechtlich abzubilden.
Wir linken an dieser Stelle auch nochmal auf den Artikel von Timo Hetzel, wo er nochmal aus eine aus Anbieterperspektive äh auf Unklarheiten Risiken und die Erpressbarkeit bei diesem Dienst,
hinweist und auch fordert. Zero Rating verbieten.
So schön das für den Kunden vielleicht auf Anhieb klingt. Das ist eine, wie nennt man, was ist da die schöne Metapher? Das ist vergiftete.
Es vergiftet, vergiftet Kost.
Genau, es gilt auch für Wikipedia im Übrigen. Der kann sich da auch ruhig mal distanzieren.
Nochmal ein bisschen was zum Thema Geheimdienste, weil da haben wir ja so wenig drüber gesprochen.
Ja. BND, NSA, eins zu eins. Äh Spiegel.
Aktueller Spielstand.
Spiegel berichtet, äh dass er Dokumente einsehen konnte, nach denen zwischen neunzehnhundertachtundneunzig und zweitausendsechs knapp viertausend Suchbegriffe in die eigenen Überwachungsprogramme
des BND eingespeist wurden, die sich gegen die USA gerichtet haben. Die Sektoren gehörten demnach
auch zu US-Regierungseinrichtungen, wie dem Finanz und Außenministerium,
sowie sogar dem weißen Haus. Überwacht wurde demnach auch der Rüstungskonzern Locket Marten. Die US Weltraumagentur NASA, militärische Stellen und sogar die Menschenrechtsorganisation Human Rights Watch.
BND hat sich dazu nicht geäußert. Ja.
Muss man nicht mehr sehr viel zu sagen, oder?
Ja der bleibt halt nur fest zu halten. Natürlich hat da keiner dieser Geheimdienste, eine weiße Weste und genau aus diesem Grund gab es ja auch den BND und NSL Untersuchungsausschuss beziehungsweise den
Geheimdienstuntersuchungsausschuss, der sicher auch den vielen Verfehlungen des deutschen Geheimdienstes zuwenden sollte.
Es überrascht wenig, aber das ist eben eine ein großes Problem, dass wir uns da als internationale Demokratien eingetreten haben.
So zum,
Schluss kommen wir nochmal auf so hm etwas größeren äh Komplex, der sich ganz gut an zwei,
äh Ereignissen,
festmachen, lässt grob gesagt, geht's um Videoüberwachung.
Äh in unterschiedlichen Manifestationen und unterschiedlichen Zielen, aber mit einer wie ich finde, kombinierten Gesamtproblematik. Vielleicht mal der erste Fall äh vorweg.
Äh real Betreiber, großer, super Märkte ähm experimentiert in vierzig,
dieser Märkte, damit äh im Kassenbereich die Gesichter von Kunden mit Kameras genau zu filmen.
Während sie auf einen Werbebildschirm schauen. Kennt man ja so Kassenausgang, Supermarkt da ja
steht man ja noch lange rum und muss so ein bisschen durch die Gegend blicken und aus dem wartenden Kunden kann man ja auch nochmal Kapital schlagen, also hängt man dann gleich nochmal ein Bildschirm auf, wenn sie schon nicht die
Meckerware da für die Kinder mitnehmen wollen, dass sie dann zumindest ein bisschen Werbung schauen, ist ja auch nochmal eine Einnahmequelle. Nur fragt sich natürlich
Schaut sich das auch einer an,
ja? Und wenn ja, wer schaut sich das an? Jetzt könnte man natürlich da irgendwelche Leute hinstellen, die das alles aufschreiben, Zahlen ist viel zu teuer,
Schön, dass es da die neue Welt gibt, denn mit,
gefilmten Gesichtern kann man heutzutage mehr machen als nur die Gesichter zu filmen. Nein, man kann auch gleich noch eine Software drüber laufen lassen, die,
weiß gar nicht, ob das hier erwähnt wurde, ob die das in Echtzeit macht oder äh später weiß ich nicht. Ist sicherlich in Echtzeit mittlerweile möglich.
Nämlich zu schauen, wo schauen die denn eigentlich hin? Das ist ja relativ einfach. Man kann heutzutage einfach in hoher Auflösung mit den Kameras die Gesichter filmen. Man findet natürlich sofort,
Augen et cetera, ich meine, wir bräuchten nur mal aktuellen,
mal so ein Selfie machen, dann seht ihr schon die Linien et cetera
die Telefone erkennen eigenständig Gesichter, Gesichter sind relativ einfach zu erkennen, das ist ein gelöstes Problem
und natürlich kann man auch die Augen erkennen und natürlich kann man auch die Blickrichtung der Augen anhand der Position der Propille erkennen und wenn man das halt dann in Relation setzt zu dem
Architektonischen Gegebenheiten des Supermarkts und dieser äh dieses Kassenausgangs dann ist es natürlich sehr einfach festzustellen, wo schauen denn die Leute hin, wo,
schauen Sie gerade auf diesen Werbebildschirm
und dann eben auch zu welchem Zeitpunkt, weil man das dann wiederum zeitlich synchronisieren kann, mit dem dort angezeigten Inhalt
Außerdem ist es heutzutage auch kein Problem, da gibt's ja schon seit Jahren äh entsprechende Studien und Testvideos im Internet zu sehen, ist es auch kein Problem, dieser Gesichtserkennung,
ähm also nicht nur die, also es geht nicht um die Identifizierung. Wer ist das? Zumindest derzeit noch nicht,
Sondern es geht eben auch um diese Information.
Wer guckt da im Sinne von wie alt Mann, Frau? Das kann man nämlich heutzutage alles rauslesen. Problemlos, ja? Also Gesichtserkennung ist soweit, dass man jemanden ein Gesicht,
brauchbarer Qualität und Auflösung filmt. Dauerhaft, dass man aus dem laufenden Video Informationen rausholen kann wie,
Wie alt ist diese Person in etwa? Handelt es sich um Mann oder Frau, aber auch lächelt diese Person, schaut die Teilnahmeslos, ja, bis hin zu,
psychischen Analysen, wie geht's dieser Person? Ist äh alles schon demonstriert worden und genau das macht halt jetzt real in diesen äh Märkten und es gab mal wieder einen kleinen Aufschrei.
Gekoppelt ist das Ganze im Übrigen auch noch mit der Auswertung von WLAN und Bluetooth Scan Informationen, das heißt, wenn die Leute ihre Telefone in der Tasche haben, kann man ja zumindest mal probieren, herauszufinden, ob man das ähm,
Gerät, was ich dort äh meldet irgendwie sehen kann.
Ähm das haben wir glaube ich hier auch schon ein paar Mal diskutiert. Das ist ja theoretisch möglich ist ähm anhand der Analyse der übergebenen Informationen beim Absuchen von,
Netzen da eine Identifikation herzustellen traditionell war da immer die Mac Adresse, also diese Netzwerkschnittstelleninformation,
sehr populär und wurde gerne genommen, weil die sich leicht zuordnen lässt in letzter Zeit
sind die Hersteller dazu übergegangen hier zufällige äh Zahlenwechsel vorzunehmen bei diesem Suchvorgang, aber auch das hilft nicht, weil,
Was ja auch so ein Klassiker ist, was wenige wissen, wenn man erstmal mit seinem Telefon in ein paar WLAN-Netzen war,
Passwort eingetragen hat et cetera. Dann erwartet man ja, dass wenn man nach Hause kommt, dass das Telefon auch automatisch reinbucht.
Jetzt aber nicht so, dass das Telefon äh sozusagen einfach drauf wartet, bis es angeklopft wird und ihm Bescheid gesagt wird, dass es sich jetzt mal einbuchen kann. Nein, es muss halt danach suchen und dazu,
schreit es quasi
Netzwerknamen auch heraus und auch da kann man halt relativ leicht eine Zuordnung machen, die man einfach mal schaut, AOG, dieses Telefon, wonach schreit es denn,
Bluetooth ähnliches, also alles was funkt, alles was in irgendeiner Form greifbar ist, einschließlich eben dieser Videoinformation,
Das wird jetzt hier rangezogen, um eine Kundenerkennung zu machen und dann eine entsprechende Analyse zu machen, welche Werbung funktioniert denn, wird hier überhaupt hingeguckt, lohnt sich das, wenn ja, welche Sachen werden eher angeschaut und welche nicht.
Ja
Frage ist, ist das jetzt irgendwie äh problematisch, also Digitalcourage, äh finden sie das gar nicht äh lustig und hat da jetzt auch schon mal eine Klage angekündigt gegen die deutsche Post AG und äh Real. Ist gerade nicht ganz klar, was hat die Post AG damit zu tun? Weißt du das.
Die haben das auch irgendwo zum Einsatz gebracht.
In Postfilialen oder wie? Wenn ich das richtig? Also überall wo man lange stehen muss.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe schon ja die äh in Realmärkten und Filialen der Deutschen Post äh wurde dieses System äh getestet.
Diese Werbedisplays filmen das halt und gucken halt, guckst du drauf, gucken auf den biometrischen Daten, sehen okay alter Mann.
Dem biete ich Old Spice an oder so. Äh junge Frau, der biete ich keine Ahnung, was irgendwie Kaugummis oder sowas, ne? Also das waren Zielgruppen, gerichtete Werbung, die er im Internet seit vielen Jahren.
Ja ihr Unwesen treibt, dass man das jetzt auch in die reale Welt trägt. Das ist das Ziel dieses Unternehmens, die diese äh Dinge Dinge baut, die Echion AG.
Die Echion AG. Ja, da wird also jetzt gegen geklagt äh ja oder angezeigt, ich finde das also die werden natürlich die,
Die Digitalcourage sagt, sie gehen da wegen Datenschutz dran. Diese Echion AG wird aber natürlich antworten mit das Ding speichert nichts. Ne? Und.
Keine Personenbezogenen Daten.
Ja, verarbeitet, die zwar, aber speichert ihn, ich denke mal, dass sie ähm dass sie das irgendwie.
Kann schon sein.
Also wir werden sehen, das wird äh wird auf jeden Fall länger dauern diese Angelegenheit.
Ja, also ich meine, vielleicht derzeit noch nicht, ja.
Machen wir uns nichts vor. Äh umso mehr Informationen, ne? Klar, kommst da rein, dein Profil passt. Aber dein Profil ist ja nicht nur, wie alt bist du?
Und wie groß bist du et cetera, sondern dein Profil kann ja dann auch immer verfeinerter werden und.
Genau. Es wird halt immer, es wird immer, es wird wirklich schwierig.
Wobei, warte mal, wenn dann unsere Hörer im Super im, dann könnten wir diese Logbohren, jetzt Politikwerbung.
Müssen wir mal anfragen.
Naja gut, aber die hören ja schon.
Dir der ähm also was,
Schwierig ist mit dieser gesamten Idee des Datenschutzes, ne? Wenn du Daten sammelst.
Kannst dich kaum dagegen wehren, dass die weitere Einsichten ermöglichen in Kombination. Also selbst wenn die jetzt sagen, ja, nee, wir wir halten das nicht dauerhaft fest, ne? Welche irgendwas werden sie ja machen,
Wenn und sei es nur, dass das dass das System merken soll, welche Werbung es nicht mehr anzeigen muss, ne? Und das heißt, bist du ruckzuck im Personen bezwungenen Bereich,
Aber das werden wir mit Interesse verfolgen. Aber weißt du, was ich viel geiler finde im Bereich der Videoüberwachung? Wir haben ja glaube ich schon über den,
Modellbahnhof Südkreuz gesprochen, ne.
In Berlin, wo die Polizei intelligente Videoüberwachung prüfen möchte, ne, also mit anderen Worten, also das worum's hier am Ende gehen wird, ist wir haben ja die,
biometrischen Daten ohnehin alle im Vollzug von den Passpässen und äh Personalausweisen, ne? Nach dem EID-Gesetz. Und jetzt sagen wir, ey, wir brauchen mal den Neumann. Wo ist der?
Wollen wir mit ihm reden. Und dann drücken die Neumann suchen, ne? Und dann hast du überall diese Videokameras, die verbunden sind mit dem mit der biometrischen Datenbank, die sie eh zentral haben. Und da macht es Piep und dann sagen die Neumann ist am Südkreuz,
schnappen.
Das ist das äh das ist das Ziel, was man immer so im Fernsehen sieht, ne? Von den Born oder wie die der Typ heißt, weil das ist als erstes gemacht. Und jetzt brauchen die natürlich, brauchen die.
Testpersonen.
Und haben sich fest, ne, solche Systeme, Systeme müssen immer trainiert werden und und geprüft werden. Da haben sie jetzt an den kompletten Bahnhof Südkreuz mit Kameras vollgehauen und haben sie gesagt, jetzt bräuchten wir eigentlich dreihundert Personen, nach denen wir mal suchen können,
Ne, dass wir einfach wissen, die sind regelmäßig da und wir möchten einfach äh unser System prüfen, ob sie, ob das sie jedes Mal erkennt.
Und dann haben sie gesagt, okay, wie kriegen wir denn jetzt, wo kriegen wir denn jetzt dreihundert Testpersonen her, diese Zahl dreihundert wird sich aus dem,
Wird sich aus dem Umsatz aus dem Traffic des Bahnhofs Südkreuz ergeben haben, dass sie sagen, wir wollen einfach jeder so und so viel tausendste
soll oder so und so viele Hundertste soll eine Person sein, die wir kennen wollen, ne, damit man halt eine ordentliche
Ratio hat eine eine übermäßige Razia zwischen solch zu erkennen, so zu nicht erkennen und dass man dann eben Alpha und Betta Fehler nach und nach aus dem System raus optimieren kann. So, was brauchst du, was machst du, wenn du dreihundert freiwillige Testpersonen brauchst? Ähm,
Hintergrund ist, dass sie natürlich noch nicht die gerechtliche Grundnulllage haben, die könnten sich auch einfach dreihundert Personen so suchen, da sie aber natürlich deren Daten speichern, brauchen sie die Einwilligung,
also zynisch wäre zu sagen, alles klar, du nimmst einfach, du nimmst dir so viele Personen, wie du willst und guckst, wer nochmal da ist und,
Guckst einfach mal alle, ne, dass du einfach mit deinen, dass du deine Überwachung mal auf äh
Fulltake fährst und sagst, wir gucken jetzt alle an und machen von jedem ein Profil, wann der Bahn gefahren ist. Darfst aber aufgrund des Datenschutzgesetzes nicht, ne? Deswegen brauchst du irgendeine Zustimmung von den Leuten, das heißt, sie müssen einmal kurz zu dir kommen und sich dafür anmelden
ne? Was machst du? Du bietest den einfachen Amazon-Gutschein für fünfundzwanzig Euro an.
Und sagst die ersten dreihundert, die in diesem Projektzeitraum äh mindestens fünf an fünfundzwanzig unterschiedlichen Tagen da waren, ja? Die kriegen den fünfundzwanzig Euro Gutschein. Außerdem können drei Testpersonen,
die an mindestens dreißig unterschiedlichen Tanken, ne? Also klar, ein bisschen öfter, ne? Ist öfter, dass du nur mal einen Tag mehr gehst, ne? Äh am häufigsten den Testbereich nutzen. Zwischen den werden Hauptpreise wie eine Apple Watch, eine Fitbit,
und eine GoProte Kamera.
Kamera äh äh verlost, ja? Das heißt also, wenn du am häufigsten durch dieses Videoding ladscht, ne, dann kriegst du noch.
Noch ein paar dreckigen Devices dazu.
Kannste noch, kannst du noch.
Ja, genau, hast du Recht, kannst du noch einen Track gegen die Weiß gewinnen.
Lassen Sie sich öfter tracken und gewinnen Sie ein Tracking.
Na ja, ich meine, ist natürlich Zielgruppe, ne? Leute, die damit kein Problem haben so, ne, haben halt auch äh ne, Leute, die dieses äh Gerät kauften, ließen sich auch gerne am Hauptbahnhof fotografieren. Also das ähm.
An, melden konntest du dich an der, an der Dienststelle der Bundespolizei, ne? Was wollst du dich da online veranmelden? Ich sag.
Könnten eigentlich auch gleich noch irgendwie eine eine Jahresmitgliedschaft bei der GFF eigentlich noch mit oben drauf legen, weil die wird man dann sowieso immer brauchen.
Ja, genau. Die haben ähm.
Ja, also dieses Angebot, ja, also ich meine, es ist ja sowas von perfide, ne? Das ist das L, fünfundzwanzig Euro, einmal hier einmal nur bei unserer hier, einmal automatisch äh scannen lassen, einmal hier unterschreiben.
Dass überhaupt fünfundzwanzig Euro geboten haben und nicht einfach nur zwei, zwei Euro fünfzig, um gleich klarzumachen, wie dreckig dieses Angebo.
Wenn die wenigstens das verfluchte BVG-Monatsticket geboten hätten, ja, das kostet aber fünfundsiebzig Euro, ja?
So, da denkst du natürlich äh also die, also ich meine.
Wie bei so vielen Nachrichten heute Dexi so äh das ist ja jetzt hier Posteo oder so, ne? Ich habe irgendwie fünf Mal geguckt, irgendwie so, dass das da nicht sein kann, also.
Nee, aber ist ernst gemeint und ähm gestern meldeten sie dann auch Vollzug. Äh sie haben ihre dreihundert Personen zusammen.
Für den Test zur automatischen Gesichtserkennung durch Videotechnik am Bahnhof Südkurz haben sich in wenigen Tagen etwa dreihundert Menschen gemeldet. Das teilte die Bundespolizei am Freitag mit. Man soll äußerst zufrieden. Man sei äußerst zufrieden mit dem Ergebnis, sagte ein Sprecher.
Also heute haben sie Lena was willst du da noch sagen? Kinder im.
Und auf auf Twitter sagte äh ein Kumpel von mir, ja ich mache da nicht für fünfundzwanzig Euro so einen Scheiß.
So, da habe ich nur geantwortet, na ja, in drei Jahren machst du das für Oma und unfreiwillig, ne? Also eigentlich kann man sagen, so das ist die einzige Möglichkeit,
dann nochmal.
Dem Staat zu schaden und ihn um fünfundzwanzig Euro zu erleichtern. Und das ist alles, was was einige wenige Glückliche von uns jemals noch äh in diesem Rahmen abgreifen können.
Ja, ich glaube, die eigentliche Diskussion, die wir jetzt hier mal aufmachen müssen, ist dieses.
Find's natürlich diese dreihundert Leute Wasser immer mit dieser Grundeinstellung mit.
Dreihundert Deppen findest du immer.
Ja, was heißt tippen? Ist halt auch so diese Egalhaltung so nach dem Motto, wie eine sowieso kommt das sowieso und überwacht, da habe ich noch was davon und so.
Vielleicht noch ganz kurz.
Und man muss ja auch erstmal verstehen, so warum besorgt uns das jetzt zum Beispiel,
Also was warum finden wir das jetzt eigentlich lustig und warum machen wir uns hier noch ein bisschen äh warum machen wir hier noch so ein paar Witze in unserer äh in unserer Art.
Die wir ja immer dem Verderben ins Auge blicken und sagen. Na und? Wir haben wenigstens noch gelacht im letzten Moment,
Warum ist das für uns so ein Thema? Na ja, weil sich das natürlich schon lange abzeichnet und dieses ganze vier auf Massenüberwachung, tralala, insbesondere Videoüberwachung. Das ist ja auch so.
Es gab doch,
Damals gab's nicht gleich nach der Wende sogar eine Berichterstattung, dass die Stasi dabei war, so eine Kette von vernetzten Videokameras durch dies Zentrum Ost Berlins aufzubauen oder Hamm aufgebaut
Und dann kam dann natürlich auch immer wieder diese Einschränkungen, na ja.
Wenn sie da so viel von gehabt haben, weil dann müssen dann Leute, da sitzen sich das anschauen und so weiter. Skaliert ja alles nicht.
Und jetzt sind wir eigentlich so an dem Punkt angekommen, wo solche Sachen auch deshalb kommen.
Weil sie auf einmal sehr billig geworden sind auf der einen Seite, also billig im Sinne von die ganze Technik, Videotechnik, Kameras und so weiter, ist alles.
Cent Ware geworden, so, ja? Also man kann.
Commodity.
Community, Technology, man kann das äh einfach es ein Abfallprodukt der technischen Entwicklung, Kameras, in brauchbarer Auflösung
Also in sehr guter Auflösung kosten nichts mehr Netzwerkübertragung et cetera, Internetverbindung anderen Netzwerktechniken kostet nichts mehr,
Aber was halt jetzt im zunehmendem Maße auch, einerseits weniger kostet und andererseits aber auch
immer mächtiger geworden ist, ist die Möglichkeit eben das alles auch auszuwerten. Gesichtserkennung war halt äh vor einiger Zeit noch äh schwierig und mittlerweile habe ich ja eben schon erwähnt bei der Sache mit äh Real und,
ist mittlerweile eben einfach geworden und dadurch äh entstehen natürlich auch ganz andere Bedrohungsszenarien an der Stelle,
und das ist nicht nur Wegen, aber eben auch, weil wir jetzt äh glaube ich in diesen Zeiten sehr wohl den Durchbruch von Artificial Intelligence
feiern können. Das war ja noch vor einigen Jahren so ein Streitthema, aber das Ding ist halt jetzt irgendwie durch. Oder? Wie siehst du das?
Ja, also vereinfacht kann man sagen, das Verhältnis aus Rechenpower und Datenmenge ist jetzt langsam
ausgeglichen, ne? Wir haben einerseits viel gebaut, was viele Daten produziert, ne? Kamen irgendwann die Digitalkameras, da fallen dann mega Pixelbilder raus. Ähm.
Da gab's auch am Anfang immer so dieses, das kann man ja gar nicht alles speichern.
Alles gar nicht speichern und was es da alles für Scherze gibt und jetzt gibt's eben drei Entwicklungen, die,
parallel gelaufen sind, erstens die Sensoren wurden billiger,
Also Kameras sind jetzt einfach überall ähm die jetzt Mikrofone auch
ähm diese die Sensoren, um überhaupt irgendwo eine Kamera hinzustellen, wurden so billig das jetzt, dass es echt Commodity ist, das heißt, du hast äh da kommt das Feld natürlich auch eine Datenfülle raus. Ähm gleichzeitig hast du natürlich dann ähm.
Die die Speicherkapazität, die wir dafür auch kriegen und die Verarbeitungsalgorithmen.
Also die Verarbeitungsspeicher und Verarbeitungsmöglichkeiten und drittens natürlich dann die Rechenpower, um das alles zu verarbeiten. Ja, das waren die, das sind die,
Punkte, die es jetzt ermöglichen im Prinzip künstlichen Intelligenzen alles beizubringen,
ich will da jetzt gar nicht so lange zu zu sprechen, aber was die meisten Artifical Intelligences, die jetzt irgendwie so diskutiert werden, sind im Prinzip Deep Learning Modelle, das heißt ähm es wird
eine neurologische Struktur nachempfunden. Wie in unserem Gehirn, in unserem Gehirn gibt es Neurone und diese Neurone können,
entweder im Ruhezustand sein und wenn sie eine, wenn ihr ihre bestimmte Schwelle überschritten wird, dann feuern sie, ne? Wenn so ein Neuron feuert, schickt es über seine ganzen Verbindungen.
An die Neurone, mit denen es verbunden ist. Ein Signal einer bestimmten Stärke. Und wenn es dann dort wieder die
jeweilige Schwelle überschreitet, dann feuert dieses Neuron, ja? Das heißt, du kannst so ein neuronales Netz durch die Schwellen jedes einzelnen äh Neurons und die Verbindung stärken aller Neurone untereinander,
ähm vollumfänglich beschreiben. Das ist äh in der Regel AI und jetzt gehst du hin und sagst, pass auf, wir wir bauen eine so eine,
so eine neuronale Struktur an der einen Seite werfen wir Informationen rein und dann brauchen wir nur ein Zielkriterium, das gut oder schlecht sein kann. Also richtig oder falsch.
Und jedes Mal, wenn du falsch zurück meldest, werden die aktiven Verbindungen, die gerade eine, die gerade gefeuert haben, geschwächt. Und jedes Mal, wenn du richtig lief, zurücklieferst, werden die gestärkt.
Und dann gibst du da einfach die ganze Zeit die gesamte Varianz dessen rein, was das System lernen soll,
ne? Also nicht auf keinen anderen Weg hat Alphago das Spiel Go gelernt. Das hat einfach so lange ähm.
Kopartien sich angeschaut.
Go Partien sich angeschaut, bis es den Bisses den bis es die Regeln von Go implizit verstanden hat.
Dann im nächsten Schritt selber Go spielen müssen, weil es ja die Regeln verstanden hat.
Dann im letzten Schritt Go gegen sich selber gespielt,
Äh um dann und dabei irgendwie keine Ahnung, die Energie von weiß ich nicht, was verballert, aber das Entscheidende ist, äh was die eigentlich.
Ist es immer Prognose, Prediktion von etwas, mit mit Feedback zur Verifikation. Relativ simple
Dinge, die auch schon vor Jahrzehnten sich ausgedacht wurden, seitdem wir wissen, dass das Gehirn so funktioniert. Ähm! Nur man hatte nicht die Rechenpower,
Und nicht die Daten, um sowas vernünftig machen zu können.
Und bis vor Kurzem auch noch nicht die wirklich verfeinerte Algorithmen
wo es ja vor ein paar Jahren Durchbruch äh gab dazu verweise ich gerne nochmal auf meinen CAE zwohundertacht von vor zwei Jahren
mich das äh diskutiert habe äh und seitdem
dass sozusagen durch ist, feuert ja alles aus allen Rohren, ne? Autos fangen an, selber äh die Straße zu erkennen und äh zu fahren und,
Ich kann euch eins sagen, also jeder, der immer noch der Meinung ist, das würde ja noch lange dauern, ja? Also ganz im Gegenteil,
Ab jetzt geht es sehr schnell,
Letzte Woche hat irgendwie Apple oder vorletzte Woche hat Apple neue tolle iPhone, also iOS Betriebssystem äh Entwicklung vorgestellt. Im Wesentlichen war das äh,
alles technologisch genau basierend auf diesem Maschinen-Learing, das heißt, das ist mittlerweile auch
In der Softwaretechnologie jetzt schon so weit, dass dieses ganze du trainierst irgendwas und wenn du das, wenn du dein dein Trainingsergebnis quasi dein dein Denkmodell ähm digital formuliert hast,
Schmeißt du das jetzt hier einfach nur noch in unser Betriebssystem an eine Stelle rein.
Kannst du das mit jedem beliebigen Programm benutzen, ne? Und damit machen sie halt auch,
so Kleinkram von QR-Code-Erkennung bis äh äh ich fotografiere meinen äh meine meine Taxiquittung auf dem äh Tisch und danach sieht sie aus, als hätte ich sie gerade schön auf dem Flach,
äh Flachbettscanner äh eingescannt.
Bis hin zu komplexeren Sachen wie oh äh ich mache hier Video und äh ich sehe, dass da ein Hund rumläuft. Und so wird sich das halt immer weiter steigern. Das heißt.
Tendenziell sind jetzt überhaupt gar keine Grenzen mehr erkennbar. Alles wird.
Trainierbar sein, also alles, wo man in irgendeiner Zwertenzahl Aussagen über
Das ist es und das ist es nicht treffen kann, wird trainierbar sein und äh da kann man sich jetzt so in die in die in die Lotusposition begeben und sich alles beliebiger ausdenken.
Und das heißt aber auch und das ist eine der wichtigen Sachen. Ich war letzte Woche bei so einer Artificial Intelligence Konferenz, ja? Und da haben sie sich alle hingestellt und meinten, meine Güte hier, guck mal, dieses
Kaffee, Framework, das ist doch alles Open Source, Artificial Intelligence für jeden hier
honorige Personen, die ernsthaft vom meinen, sie würden jetzt, ne, Arthifische Intelligence wäre jetzt auch Commodity,
Und das ist eben nicht der Fall, weil du brauchst diese Massen an Lernmaterial,
Das ist das, was du brauchst, um die zu trainieren. Ja klar, du kannst solange du Daten hast, kannst du deine AI trainieren. Dann lade dir doch mal so einen Kaffee runter und gucke mal, ob du irgendwie Trainingsdaten dafür hast.
Ja? Das heißt, die, die wirkliche Macht der AI geht an jene, die viele Daten haben,
Das sind dummerweise echt einige sehr wenige. Zufälligerweise übrigens auch die, die sehr viel Computing Power haben, ja? Kannst ja mal deine AI Experimente machen
So was du was du da an CPUs brauchst und so, ne? Ich habe mal meinen acht Kern XON ein bisschen AI machen lassen. Da habe ich aber schnell äh mir anders überlegt.
Unten nämlich so ein Ding dran habe, was den Strom zählt und gleichzeitig mir ausrechnen konnte, wie lange der braucht. Wenn du dir jetzt mal so dieses Alpha-Go anschaust, ne?
Alphago hat in der Distribute Variante irgendwie sowas wie Anja in zweitausend CPUs und zweihundert GPUs warm gemacht. Ne? Äh und das nur um diesen,
relativ einfachen und das, ne, man also äh um diese Komplexität von des Spieles go.
Da hätte ich ja übrigens noch einen Vorschlag für äh wie man dieses Mensch-Versus Maschineding noch für ein paar Jahre spannend machen kann, indem man nämlich sagt.
Die beiden Teilnehmer an diesem Spiel dürfen auch nur in etwa dieselbe Menge an Kalorien verbrauchen, während sie dieses Spiel äh durchführen.
Das ist natürlich insofern gemein, weil ja im Prinzip man äh auch alle Kalorien, die bis dahin schon verbraucht worden sind, auch noch mit berechnen muss und das ist natürlich die Computer, die also ich bin mir sicher, dass dieser Alphago-Computer deutlich mehr Energie verbraucht hat, als jeder, der Spieler dieser gewonnen hat
in dem ganzen Leben bereits verbraucht hat, ja?
Drauf an, ob der Spieler ähm Vegetarier ist oder nicht, aber da kommen wir in Details. Da kommen wir in.
Vegetarische Supercomputer brauchen wir.
Ähm was ich eigentlich ganz spannend finde, ist also bei Go, ne, die Komplexität von Go ist ja glaube ich zehn hoch einhundertsiebzig, wenn ich das richtig,
wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe und die Komplexität des Universums oder die Anzahl der Atome im Universum ist zehn hoch achtzig. Mit anderen Worten du bräuchtest für jeden,
Für jedes Atom im Universum nochmal ein eigenes Universum, um die Komplexität des Spieles Go abzubilden, ne,
Mit anderen Worten das wird so als der absolute Durchbruch gesehen, wenn dass das besser als der Mensch kann, dann ist wirklich klar, dass es alles besser als der Mensch kann.
Ähm spannend finde ich nur die Regeln von Go sind eigentlich relativ wenig. Und wenn man sich überlegt, wie viel Computing Power,
Und wie viele lern durch Mechanismen, die brauchten, bis der Computer endlich mal besser war als der Mensch und dann auch nur an diesem einen relativ wenigen Regeln unterliegenden Spiel. Dann kann man eigentlich auch sagen, ey
aber Hut ab vor Van Hui,
gegen den Alphagor da gezockt hat, dass er es überhaupt geschafft hat, sich mit so einer Rechenpower mit so viel Energie, mit so vielen Prozessoren, mit vierzig Suchtrads ähm zu messen.
Also das äh finde ich eigentlich auch mal eine andere Perspektive an an diese Komplexität, auf diese Komplexität zu blicken. Dennoch hast du natürlich Recht, wir sind wir sollten hier überhaupt nicht uns zurücklehnen und lächeln bei dieser AI-Kram wird uns jetzt ruck zuck überholen und die Macht der AI ist bei der, bei denjenigen, die die Macht der Daten haben
die Macht der Rechenpower. Und das ist äh nicht unbedingt eine so geile Zukunftsvision.
Ja und da redet man halt dann irgendwie auch nicht mehr nur über Datenschutz oder so. Also der Begriff wird da äh etwas äh dünn,
und ähm man muss sich klar machen, also ich will jetzt auch nicht immer so gleich äh wieder mit so einem apokalyptischen Szenario daherkommen, nur.
Die Einschätzung dessen, was hier gemacht wird, ja, so dieses wir machen ja nur X. Wir tun ja dies,
jetzt gerade noch nicht, ja? Ähm in zwei, drei Jahren ist das ist das Ding durch,
jeder, der irgendwie große Datenmengen äh sammelt. Viele Leute tun das, viele Organisationen
tun hast, werden noch sehr viel mehr damit anfangen, die wir bisher noch nicht damit angefangen haben,
mit diesen AI Methoden da drüber gehen. Das
beschränkt sich halt jetzt nicht nur so auf diese diese ganze Überwachungs und Auswertungs äh Geschichte. Das geht zum Beispiel auch in die Anfangssendung auch nochmal aufgebrachte Sicherheitsfrage, ne? Sicherheitsarchitekturen
et cetera, also Bots scannen ja heutzutage schon das Internet ab und äh suchen nach irgendwas
demnächst wird man wahrscheinlich nur noch mit so einer digitalen Streustrahlung durch dieses Netz.
Gehen und anhand der Antworten verschiedener Systeme äh,
quasi Mutmaßungen darüber aufstellen können, was für äh,
Schwächen dort vorliegen. Also ganz andere Dimensionen der Auswertung und deswegen ist das unter anderem so bedrückend äh zu sehen, dass wir
politisch auf eine Richtung gehen, wo er sagt, so ja, nee, wir müssen hier Sicherheits äh aus Sicherheitsterrorwägung müssen wir jetzt irgendwie dieses Thema auch unsicher halten, damit wir dann noch irgendwie eine Chance haben. So, ja nie
wir müssen
Kultur kommen, wo wir so schnell wie möglich dagegen vorgehen und alles so sicher machen. Ganz im Gegenteil, wir sollten eher darüber nachdenken, äh AI Methoden äh,
verwenden, um möglichst sichere Systeme erzeugen zu können.
Das steht einfach an. Also wir sind an den nächsten.
Großrevolution, nachdem wir irgendwie Telefon äh durch hatten und dann kam äh Internet, dann kam Smartphone so und jetzt ist,
AI-Welle steht vor der Tür. Wir haben's euch gesagt.
Ja, nicht gut.
Ihr zuerst gehört ja so viel äh zu den apokalyptischen Reitern. Umsonst noch was.
Den den Sommer haben wir angesprochen, dass die Erscheinungsfrequenz unter Umständen leidet.
Genau, also können wir jetzt nicht so richtig, also im August, im August wird's dünner und äh kann sein, dass wir dann noch ein paar andere äh Sendungen so nach Terminlage, wie sich's ergibt machen. Ähm keine Versprechungen.
Ja
Alles schon durch.
Wir warten einfach bis die nächste äh Regierung kommt und dann geht der ganze Quatsch wieder von vorne los.
Damit bleibt zu danken dem Philipp Alexander dem Karlis sehr, sehr verspätet. Äh Johannes, Markus Thomas und einer unbekannten Person, deren,
Paket hier in die Meta-Ebene ging. Ich hoffe, du weißt, dass du gemeint bist.
Genau und wir danken auch noch den zahlreichen anderen Unterstützern, Einzelspendern und Leuten, die immer.
Anderen Leuten sagen, dass sie Luft und Netzpolitik hören sollen. Ist nämlich auch gut.
Ein drei Tages. Die Welt einen besseren Ort zu machen.
So, das war's. Blockbundespolitik heute ganz ohne Trump, sagen wir mal was.
Hören wir auf. Ciao, ciao.
Bis bald. Ciao, ciao.